Guten Morgen Tim.
Wir bauen einfach das nicht durchschritten etera mit 5g aus dann muss ich Peter Altmaier und nicht mehr beim Telefonieren schämen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 278 etwas verspätet dafür aber so richtig schön in eurem Stiefel denn heute ist ja der 6.12
2018 und ihr wundert euch sicherlich schon was wir euch alles mitgebracht haben.
Ja herzlichen Glückwunsch einen Adventskalender vor Botschaften.
Erstmal erstmal müssen wir Vokabeln glaube ich machen nicht dafür haben selten ein Intro gehabt was so deep war wie heute das war digidi.
Das war mehrlagig multidimensional.
Das war mehr vielschichtig das war.
Edemissen Erinnern an der verflochtene er ist die Stringtheorie des des politischen Diskurses.
Na gut das ist ringtheorie was ich wollte noch was ich wollte noch was loswerden aber komme gleich zu also erstmal Intro erklären unser besser im Moment Wirtschaftsminister ne.
Woher Kanzleramtsminister jetzt Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier schämt sich.
Es ist ihm total peinlich im Auto mit ausländischem Minister Kollegen zu telefonieren warum weil allein andauernd die Gespräche abbrechen.
Hat er gesagt auf irgendeiner Bühne.
Weiß ich bei welcher Veranstaltung ein ich auch egal Peter geht mir nicht anders tut mir leid ich kann da nichts für vielleicht kannst du da als Wirtschaftsminister auch nicht so wirklich was für.
Wär schön wenn man das irgendwie in Griff kriegen würden so weil mir ist es auch peinlich wirst es auch regelmäßig.
Sein Vorgänger der war doch noch.
Immer nichts peinlich dem man nichts.
Lieber hätte ich mal gespannt ich habe der fühlte sich ja zumindest noch zuständig.
Noch nicht dass es irgendwas geholfen hätte aber schon hart.
Was haben wir noch genau Neuland ist jetzt nicht durchschritten estera.
Ja das muss man mal das muss man mal abspielen ja das ist großartig Merkel läuft ja sowieso zu neuer Form auf jetzt ne.
Ja so könnte man das sagen immerhin kannst es mit Humor nehmen.
Wird ihr ja ohnehin unterstellt von Insider dass sie ja sehr sehr spitzen Humor hätte ich freue mich darauf den nächsten Jahr dann auch mal mehr auspacken.
Ich bin mal gespannt werden jetzt in Deutschland noch beabsichtigt diese Szene zu durchschreiten.
Den Eindruck hat man gerade nicht dass jemand da noch durch will.
Also die wollen doch schon alle durch aber die hoffen dass es dann auch wieder vorbei ist ne c mit die CeBIT Tim als als alter Hannoveraner der muss ja in der Seele weh tun.
Mehr noch ist bin auch wirklich ein altes ich bin richtiges CeBIT Kind ich kenne das wirklich von Anfang an.
Es gibt auch von Anfang an Videos von dir im Internet ne auf der CeBIT.
Ja gibt's auch.
Ich kann zusätzlich noch nicht.
Sehr unerfahrener Pritlove der im Fernsehen tu nicht daran denkt die Person mit der er redet auch mal anzugucken,
Computerbildschirm Kopf und sich von diesem störenden Menschen den irgendwie möglichst kurze ewig wieder loswerden zu wollen.
Ja die haben alle die die.
Ungestört.
Heraldische nicht verstanden und so oder war ich noch richtig schön überheblicher nerd.
Fuehrt sicher.
Bin etwas nachsichtiger.
Jajaja.
Alter profitierst du auch von.
Dieses Video verlinken.
Ja habe ich einen zum Schmied.
Okay bist einfach noch hierhin Video von dem Verlegen.
Ja aber man kann sagen die CeBIT war für mich ein wichtiger Begleiter ich habe ja damals nicht nur in Hannover sondern auch in unmittelbarer Nähe dieses Messegeländes gewohnt.
Und auch in unmittelbarer des unmittelbarer Nähe des unbestochnen los noch nicht durchschritten intera.
Na ja da also wenn irgendwo das Terra durchschritten wurde dann schon auf der CeBIT ich meine wir hatten ja immer das Privileg dass jegliche neue Technik da immer zuerst kam,
ISDN und all diese ganzen Geschichten das wurde ja erstmal in Hannover in meinem Wohnbezirk installiert.
Hast du damit.
Damit man das auf DC bezeichnen kann ja wir hatten also da und insofern war für mich die CeBIT Schlaraffenland weil,
was auch immer irgendwann mal kommen sollte hat in Hannover zuerst Funktion,
und das war für mich durchaus Grund und hat sicherlich auch eine ganze Menge drumherum gezogen also auch das heiße mit seinem ganzen,
digitalen in Hannover ist,
hat schon auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun dass sie da Messestandort doch schon ne ganze Menge mit sich gezogen hat und der war natürlich auch so ein bisschen so der der der jährliche Spielplatz unserer Szene mein ganzen CCC habe ich auf der CeBIT kennengelernt,
das war für mich firstcontact und für viele andere auch und vor allem eines ob ich das in so einem Tweet auch aus.
Drückt als als diese Nachricht rumgehen,
dass du die CeBIT für uns damals und jetzt rede ich halt wirklich von 80er Ende der 80er jahre Anfang der 90er Jahre war quasi für uns so das Internet was es noch nicht gab,
weil da kannst du halt hingehen und dir alle Datenblatt herunterladen.
Wo solltest du denn sonst herkriegen
Japan netzkappen Compuserve keinen Cancan irgendwas Webseiten und so weiter wenn du dich,
über Computertechnologie in irgendeiner Form informieren wolltest war so halt auf
Bücher angewiesen oder du musst es halt Firmen kennen die
sowas hatten wo wo Material rum lag war nichts im Download verfügbar Mailbox Zeiten das war so
ganz am Anfang alles noch aber war halt wenig digital verfügbar auf der CeBIT Konzerte ich von Stand zu Stand,
Rennen und fallen ersten Jahren noch mit den Leuten reden die das wirklich alles gebaut haben also er war ja noch so richtig die die original engineers am Start.
Das muss ganz toll gewesen sein.
Das Buch Gasthäuser kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Warum ist es weg.
Weils einfach schon lange aus der Zeit gefallen.
Also als Messe war es natürlich auf mehreren Ebenen für Leute wichtig für uns dieses Jahr.
Dann soll den frühen 2000ern.
Es ist ja so kulturell dann irgendwie verfallen also da hat er das erstens das Internet das ersetzt so überhaupt die ganze Zeit runter Kommunikation auch der bessere Transport also auch für dieses wo man sich trifft und wie man sich trifft hat sich ja verbessert,
und dann haben die halt da mit ihrem Essen noch weiter gemacht wir hatten ja wenn Ihre Hochphase glaube ich,
2002/3 oder so wurden diese mega CeBIT mit 650.000 Besuchern war.
Hat dich jetzt glaube ich auf Einzelgehöft mit 800 gelesen.
Ja ich meine das ja jetzt die Zeit gewesen auf viva Unfassbare,
Menschenmassen sagen muss die beste zählt ja dann wie das alle Messen machen immer jeden Tag quasi und wenn es die dieselbe Person ist die da kommt dann wird die halt auch einmal gezählt ne also hast du sang,
multiples von Tages Besuchern yaglarindan alle also gepimpt.
Also.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall die Analysen bei Heise ganz interessant wo auch mal tatsächlich gesagt wird ok welche strategischen Entscheidung wurden im Rahmen dieser Messe getroffen ja so irgendwie.
Einmal die quasi nachher zu bereuen der Fehlentscheidung daraus irgendwie als Business Messer aufstellen zu wollen die nicht
das natürlich den Leuten die Motivation genommen hat dort unbedingt Ihre neuesten Produkte vorstellen zu wollen das irgendwie so quasi kritisiert wurde oder versucht wurde dem Einhalt zu gebieten das da die sogenannten Beutelratten rumgerannt sind also.
Fitnessmesse war es schon immer aber sie sahen sich genötigt das quasi Business only zu machen und das war schon kein guter.
Das war kein guter move und jetzt haben sie es letztes Jahr da mit dem Riesenrad und eine Rutsche irgendwie versucht im Prinzip in Richtung Republica.
Na mehr so south by Southwest.
Irgendwie so war es wieder eine und auf dem Mund der das haben sie verkackt glaube ich ich denke nicht.
Dass die Zeit für iTeam Essen vorbei ist ganz im Gegenteil ich lerne nur ich lerne immer wieder von neuen ja was weiß ich Consumer Electronics Show von den Mobile World Congress.
Das neue die ces.
Ja aber ja genau aber die werden die werden immer einflussreicher.
Ja aber das ist eine consumer schon das ist sowas wie die wie die die IFA die gibt.
Hier ist das völlig egal er geht auch keiner hin dass das,
ja oft auf der CeBIT sind auch noch welche hingegangen also es ist eine überraschende man hat dieses Sichtung der CeBIT über die Jahre natürlich mitbekommen ging immer weniger Leute in der hat auch haben eben auch die großen.
Es kam halt vor allem auch immer weniger Firmen also das.
Wetter nicht mehr hin die haben keine.
Die Kleinen nicht mehr VII der Aufwand lohnt sich halt auch einfach nicht Apple hat die CeBIT schon vor ewigen Zeiten verlassen,
weil sie einfach gesehen haben dass sie mit jeder Mac wird Krieg Keynote mehr Leute erreichen als sie dafür das Zehnfache an Geld kontaktieren können deswegen ist sie sich das ist,
das Konzept Messe ist schon bisschen angewandt worden so und man muss sich schon auf das konzentrieren was in der Messe am besten kann das nervig
die Kontakte die treffen und so weiter weil die Besonderheit der CeBIT war natürlich schon dass sie auch immer so der Ort des neuen war dass man irgendwie auch Informationen bekommen konnte die man
woanders so nicht bekommen hat das viel Halt in zunehmendem Maße weg,
sind wundert mich das nicht dazu kommt noch dass diese Konzentration auf wir sind jetzt die gesamt Messe für alle Branchen alles was irgendwie mit bis zu tun hat das war,
als der ganze Computer Kram neu war Neunzigern und daneben auch noch so in 2001.
Nachvollziehbar da waren zu Computer als solche sozusagen noch eine News das ist aber jetzt einfach so,
Thema aller Branchen geworden du beschäftigt sich immer mit Computern und von daher ist eigentlich die Rücküberführung des Seevetal Cindy,
Hannover Messe Industrie wo sie herkommt das war ja mal eine Halle da,
wahrscheinlich sogar das richtige so dass die CeBIT einfach als als separate Veranstaltung nicht mehr lebt kann ich ganz gut nachvollziehen also hat ihre Arbeit geleistet für eine bestimmte Zeit war es sinnvoll aber jetzt.
Ähnlich wie Großbritannien.
Oh ja na die sind noch nicht weg ich bin Optimist.
Du bist optimistisch dass.
Der brexit noch fehlt.
D&D felt so oder so.
Failed der Welt sowie sehr genau das dass er dass er noch abgesagt wird weil eigentlich wenn man es mal,
ja wenn man mal schaut was jetzt eigentlich passiert ist ist das eigentlich die letzte verbleibende Option für die Briten mit der Sie den Kopf noch aus der Schlinge ziehen kann,
was passiert die Verhandlungen zwischen Großbritannien und der EU sind abgeschlossen worden und misses May.
Premiere Ministerin hat dann einen tollen Plan vorgestellt dass es jetzt hier unser Abkommen Wer ist es nicht im Einzelnen so aufdröseln aber im Kern,
sag dieser Plan eigentlich nur alles bleibt wie es ist wir haben bloß nichts mehr zu sagen,
und die politische Zukunft wie denn irgendwann mal die EU mit Großbritannien aufgestellt sein soll wird in die Zukunft,
verschoben weil da gibt es nur so ein absichts Papier von den 585 Seiten des Austritts Vertrages der quasi die Übergangsregelungen definiert,
nur so ein verschwindend geringer Teil oder soll ich glaube es noch ein kleines Zusatz Papier der quasi nur so eine Absichtserklärung ist mit naja worauf man sich vielleicht irgendwann mal unter Umständen einigen könnte aber überhaupt nichts Wichtiges ist nur so ein Rheine.
Man könnte ja mal drüber nachdenken Nummer im Wesentlichen wird aber durch diesen Plan voran dieser Irrsinn
festgeschrieben der sich ja eh schon abgezeichnet hat das haben wir ja hier auch schonmal debattiert das quasi sichergestellt sein muss das Nordirland und Irland nicht auseinander getrieben werden,
das ist halt einfach nach wie vor der Klumpfuss in der ganzen Geschichte wo es einfach keine Lösung gibt zu Großbritannien man kann eigentlich feststellen,
es ist nicht möglich zu Miss Großbritannien nicht möglich die EU zu verlassen und sich dabei komplett selbst zu ruinieren oder sich in so eine dauerhafte Fremdbestimmung zu begeben und genau das wäre natürlich jetzt dieser Deal spricht,
EU Gesetz würde auf absehbare Zeit oder sag mal auf unabsehbare Zeit weiter gelten.
Defacto gibt's überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit und wenn dann irgendwann mal in ferner Zeit in vielen Jahren sie dann vielleicht doch auf irgendeinem Plan kommen wie sich daraus lösen können.
Ist alles schon alles vorbei
weil das Schlimmste für die Wirtschaft ist natürlich Unsicherheit und diese Unsicherheit wird hier noch fortgeschrieben dementsprechend ist der Aufstand groß und wir haben in dieser Woche schon einiges bemerkenswertes erlebt die Regierung hat gleich die ersten 3 Abstimmungen,
verloren
wo es darum ging dass sie bestimmte Informationen nicht preisgeben wollte dazu ist jetzt gezwungen worden so eine rechtliche Einschätzung wahrscheinlich für sich genommen gar nicht so ein großes Ding aber symbolisch insofern sehr wichtig als dass eben
die tolles schon an der Stelle ihre reinigt zusammenhalten können und alle gehen davon aus dass die eigentliche Abstimmung ohne diesen Plan stattfindet
dieser Deal abgespeichert wird also sie keine Mehrheit finden und so gibt halten das hatte ich ja hier auch schonmal gesagt eigentlich keine Mehrheit für überhaupt irgendwas,
die EU wird natürlich jetzt überhaupt die wird sich hinstellen sagen ja was wollt ihr denn ihr habt jetzt mit uns verhandelt wir machen das jetzt seit zwei Jahren mehrfach keinen Bock mehr so geht kacken,
und wir machen es hier nicht noch irgendwas ist vorbei geht bitte also entweder ihr geht oder er bleibt.
So und wir gehen könnt haben wir ja abgezeichnet und wenn ihr euch darauf nicht einigen können ja dann keine Ahnung dann,
finde die Bombe an dir euch da selber gebastelt habt oder,
sag die Scheiße einfach ab ist ja sowieso am liebsten dass du die Position der EU und damit sind sie mittlerweile sehr stark weil du bist die ganze Zeit geschafft haben eigentlich immer auf alles einzugehen was sie so UK meinte zu wollen auch wenn sie das nicht so genau formulieren können.
Tulis vermieden haben so sich irgendwie groß auf zu,
bauschen und Druck auszuüben Samson Druck ausgeübt aber nur indem sie gesagt haben na ja wir sind unsere Regeln die kennt er ja ja selber mit beschlossen oder 40 Jahre.
Und jetzt steht UK so ein bisschen mit leeren Händen da und ich finde das lustig ist mich so ein bisschen wie bei Douglas Adams mir irgendwie aufgefallen die Sache mit dem großen Computer der lange darüber nachdenkt was denn nun die Antwort auf die Frage nach dem Leben dem Universum den ganzen Rest ist.
Und die Antwort ist 42.
Die Antwort ist 42 dann standen sie alle da so ein bisschen wieder dieses brexit-votum so ja die Antwort war halt wir wollen raus,
und dann war halt die Frage naja aber was genau heißt das jetzt eigentlich wie wie war denn die Frage eigentlich formuliert und das weiß halt keiner,
das müssten Sie eigentlich noch größere Computer Bach und der ewig viele Millionen Jahre drüber nach rechnet Wurst was denn jetzt eigentlich die Frage gewesen ist damit man diese Antwort deuten kann und das natürlich komplett unmöglich
dass die Situation in der wir uns jetzt befinden wenn also diese das Votum scheitert wovon ich ausgehe wovon alle ausgehen,
kann natürlich auch anders kommen aber danach siehts aus.
Latina dich nichts anderes als klein beizugeben noch mal ein zweites Referendum zu machen und ich bin mir relativ sicher weil das Referendum sagt,
sorry aber ja Politiker die politische Klasse hat es nicht geschafft hier in irgendeiner Form irgendwas zu machen bevor wir uns alle komplett ruinieren bleibe doch lieber drin.
Da müsste aber irgendwie im Moment gibt's doch niemanden der darauf abzielt ein neues Referendum zu machen von den Parteien es gibt diese Bürgerbewegung Bürger ich weiß nicht ob wir das halt TV2.
Spiele Jan,
na ja es ist es ist nicht man kann es mittlerweile nicht mehr an den Parteien festmachen das ist ein Riss der durch alle Parteien gibt es gibt bei den Torres welche es gibt bei den Barleber welche die,
mehrheitlich für peoples wo sind also bei Leber mehrheitlich bei Tory Minderheit nicht die SNP Scottish National Party ist komplett dafür,
septemb sowieso
die haben ist nicht viele Sitze aber wenn es ein Parteien festmachen Whisky Parteien sind die Grünen also grünen Lipton zum essen Pilsen komplett für peoples wodewa mehrheitlich und torias inhaltlich und so dass sie halt das machen kann und dann ist es halt diese
DOP diese irische
nordirische Fraktion war die weiß was sie will die ehrlich die ganze Zeit nur rumschreit wir wollen genauso ein Scheiß dir haben wie
Großbritannien keine Sonderrechte für uns,
das ist alles nicht mehr nachvollziehbar und so entspannt sich das ist also wenn man sich gerade mal die Berichterstattung anschaut es ist zum Haare raufen ein einziges Chaos sowas gab es noch nie kann wirklich eine Zeitenwende sein,
mein Tipp brexit will abgesagt.
Da gibt es aber bitteschön oder eine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft.
So ist das denn da hast du die einmal im Land ne.
Ja das habt ihr.
Wir gehen nie wieder.
So okay da da war schon mal eine Wette bin ich gespannt wie sie wie die sich ergeben wird mal schauen ob der noch weitere werden hier heute unterbringen will CDU Nachfolge CDU Vorsitz Nachfolge März.
Camp Karel.
Ithaka Kaka.
Sag mir hat.
Türkei.
5 Mark bewertung 5 Mark hast du noch 5 Mark ich habe noch 15 Mal scheint aber den will ich eigentlich gerne behalten 5 € wetten wir zahlbar an der Bar des 35 C3,
oder oder am Späti genau mal gucken was in schonkoste wäre für 5 € Zweifel kriegen.
Ja der CDU Vorsitz ist meiner ist interessant meinte ich könnte beiden beiden Wahlergebnissen wir gehen jetzt beide mal davon aus dass Herr Spang keine Chance hat was abgewinnen.
März wird das wenn März das gewinnt dann deshalb weil der im Prinzip seit Wochen die mediale Auseinandersetzungen,
in Einzel berichten bestimmt ob der irgendein Vorschlag zur Steuernachlass bei Aktienhandel macht,
ob der ob die Leute sich damit auseinandersetzen dass er ja ein Schwertträger der des Mittelstands ist,
mit einer groben Millionen Jahreseinkommen
statt sich damit auseinanderzusetzen bei was für Leuten mit was für einer arbeitet dieses Geld verdient hat ob man sich damit auseinandersetzt dass der ein Flugzeug hat der hat es geschafft und das.
Mehrere mehr als 1.
Da muss man vermieten habe ich doch schon hundertmal erklärt wenn du wenn du solche Luxusgüter besitzt dann musst du die vermieten,
ja sonst kriegst du die von der Steuer nicht abgesetzt,
möchte doch mal erzählt oder den Begriff habe ich von meiner jetzt hätte ich fast Steuerberaterin gesagt alles weil die Frau vom Finanzamt bei der Steuerprüfung da gibt's ja diese Yacht Vermieter.
Wir haben das ganze Jahr über die Yacht und einmal im Jahr vermieten sie die für vier Wochen an irgendwelche Freunde für 1000 €,
und dann müssen sie aber quasi den die Anschaffung der Yacht die Wartung der Jagd in Liegeplatz und so alles absetzen weil sie jagt Vermieter sind so ungefähr ist das mit den Flugzeugen auch
aber Flugzeug in der türlich die holst du dir mit mehreren oder so und dann bist du schnell in so einer Situation dass ihr wie steuerlich auch Geld zu machen aber lassen wir die Steuertricks Steuertricks ich würde ganz ehrlich sagen dass der Friedrich Merz sich mit solchen Steuertricks
tatsächlich nicht auseinandersetzt
der ist ja eher zum mit cum cum cum Ex und so das war ja eher so März Teil Steuerbetrüger mein kleinvieh macht auch Mist aber jetzt irgendwie dem.
Du hast Recht darüber redet keiner.
Darüber redet keiner und so wird er soll auch über die anderen Bewerberinnen und Bewerber auf den CDU Vorsitz die haben nicht in Einzel Berichterstattung,
die die Medien geschafft ja es war entweder eakk März span Berichte,
oder März Berichte und deswegen wird er wird es der März hinkriegen zweiter Faktoren,
das ist ja so die alte anti-merkel Garde merkst du ja auch hier der Schäuble und so der jetzt ja die Empfehlungen ausgesprochen hat und so und,
da in der CDU gibt's ja auch eine größere merkel-muss-weg Funktion Fraktion und dann evidas erstarrten der AFD was für die
CDU ein Problem ist die möchten natürlich nicht dass die dass die AFD so ungefähr die Linkspartei der CDU wird ja und da glaube ich dass sie am ehesten sich am Ende dazu hinreißen lassen
den den März zu werden das nur zur Begründung meiner.
Ich habe meine.
Ich möchte ja Unrecht haben ja.
Ja also ich meine ich finde nicht wirklich sagen dass meine Seele tief in das in die Seele der CDU eingetaucht ist ich.
Die sagen wir mal so die CDU ist für uns beide ja noch nicht durchschritten ist Ehre.
Wachsen.
Für die ist schon lange da aber wir haben uns eigentlich nie dran gewöhnt so das ist mein fremdelt immer noch so damit ne.
Altland für mich ist das Alte Land.
Atlas.
Wollte schon früher nicht durchschreiten ja gut also ich meine.
Volkspartei hin und her wenn sie alleine ist ja dann könnte sich das tatsächlich in der Wahl von Akk aus
ja weil sie wie merke irgendwie so ein bisschen alles und nichts ist auch wenn sie da versucht sich zu definieren
März wäre halt die klare konservative Kante von früher Anna-Sophie Kohl hier konservative Revolution oder was auch immer sie da irgendwie machen geistig moralische Wende hieß das damals in 80er Jahren unter Kohl sollen sie mal ruhig machen
ja also mit März ist Mist.
Immer der März vor hat ne das kann man zur Geist sich das wird eine geistig-moralische Wende aber das wird nicht dadurch ausgezeichnet sein dass sie moralisch ist ne das sollte man da schon.
Ja aber ich meine das Gute wäre man dann ist zumindest sicher Merkel immer schön im Zoo.
Also ergibt auf den Beinen besseres Feindbild im politischen Diskurs ab und würde in der linken und damit meine ich quasi alles was rechts von der CDU links von der CDU ist.
Eine größere Reibungsfläche zum abarbeiten.
Also könnte sozusagen auch positiven Effekt.
Naja okay wo sitzt der Büttel farfetched aber könnte auch einen positiven Aspekt geben.
A2 Witten offen mal gucken wie es aus.
Ende kommt der sparen und wir müssen uns warten halten.
Dann spenden wir das an einem.
Ich bin mir das an.
An den erstbesten geradeaus beim Späti Wollwickler.
Okay so also wenn wenn verlieren dann richtig ist okay dann haben wir.
Den Anschluss an die letzte Sendung die Vergabebedingungen für die 5g Auktionen stehen fest.
Man kann sich also nun für die Auktion bewerben ja könnt ihr also jetzt euren Lebenslauf hinschicken und.
Also zuviel kurz zusammengefasst.
Essen sollen die etablierten Netzbetreiber sollen in irgendeiner Form angeregt sein mit neuen Einsteigern zumindest zu verhandeln Zweifelsfall möchte die Regulierungsbehörde da Sünde in der sich in einer Schiedsrichter Rolle sehen.
Dann antworten findet nicht statt.
Anbieter.
Wie jetzt also eine diese 5g Lizenzen ersteigern müssen bis Ende 20 20 20 22 jeweils 98% der Haushalte in den Ländern mit,
100Mbit versorgen.
Weißt du doch das ist doch wirklich eine Frau kann sie ersparen das ist ja nur downstream ne wobei das so tut man also sehen dann dann.
98% der Haushalt.
In den Ländern das ist im Zweifelsfall auch noch mal
eine Abschwächung gegenüber 98% der Haushalte im Bundesgebiet wenn man nämlich auf die Fläche schaut ja wenn jetzt irgendwie Länder hast die sehr wenig Fläche haben und nimmst davon 98% der Haushalte dann kann das am Ende sehr viel mehr Fläche bedeuten die du nicht versorgen musst als wenn es auf die ganz auf das ganze Bundesgebiet.
Interessant ist ja ohnehin die Formulierung 98% der Haushalte ja also 98% der Fläche wäre meine Ansage gewesen aber so.
Ich würde das nur gerne zusammenfassen aber das in der letzten Sendung relativ ausführlich besprochen haben also die das Für und Wider und die Abwägung haben wir ja besprochen ich würde jetzt gerne nur kurz mal zusammenfassen,
jeder Netzbetreiber muss 1000 Basisstation für 5g bis Ende 22.22 aufbauen,
vorausgesetzt es gibt die notwendige Technik es gibt es die nicht gibt gibt ein Aufschub bis 20-24 das ist auch so eine typische Regel wenn du also Lizenz Bänder Lizenzen,
erlangst dann musst du die bis zum gewissen Zeitpunkt auch nachweislich nutzen jetzt denkt man natürlich 1000 Basisstation ist das viel oder wenig.
Naja für GSM in Deutschland betreibst du so im Bereich von 25000,
das ist irgendwie als Netzbetreiber also 1000 ist da mehr oder weniger eine gute Willensbekundung ne du musst es halt auch irgendwo mal in Betrieb nehmen.
Entlang der Autobahn und wichtigsten Bundesstraßen sowie der Schienenstrecken
mit mehr als 2000 Fahrgäste täglich soll bis Ende 2020 soll es bis Ende 2020 mindestens 100 Mbit gegen geben bis Ende 20-24
auch entlang der weiteren Bundesstraße Landstraße Wasserwege und so weiter.
Soll also quasi ein paar Vorlagen und dann die Latenz Vorgabe mit 10 Millisekunden für die Netze an Autobahnen und Bundesstraßen geht dann auch.
Und eine Pflicht zum nationalen Roaming dass er ja sehr umstritten waren wir auch in der letzten Sendung gesprochen soll es dann nicht,
verpflichtend geben aber es gibt einen verhandlungs Gebot mit der Bundesnetzagentur als Schiedsstelle naja,
wir sind mal gespannt.
Ich fasse mal kurz zusammen das wird schon alles scheiße bleiben.
Keine Sorge das bleibt schon alles scheiße.
Also das ist es wird nicht besser dadurch ist er Banzai ganze Heckmeck den sie machen jetzt um 5 Uhr gehe ich mal was heißt denn 5g überhaupt 5 kg heißt einfach noch ein etwaiges Protokoll,
höhere Frequenzen und das ganze ist halt optimiert auf Highspeed Zugänge,
in Nahbereichs heiße Zellen sind sehr viel kleiner theoretisch könnte man auch,
andere Frequenzen damit bedienen das ist ja nicht so dass das Protokoll jetzt auf der Frequenz festgelegt wäre auf einer LTE geht das ja von 700 Megahertz bis 2,
weiß nicht mehr genau sechs oder so und neue Technologie erlaubt halt jetzt die Nutzung von noch höheren Frequenz und das Protokoll ist brechend angepasst,
am Ende finde ich eigentlich viel interessanter,
wie der LTE-Ausbau denn jetzt hier noch vorangeht weil das ist ja nun auch noch nicht abgeschlossen hätte ja auch einfach sagen können neuer 5g kriegt den Lizenzen aber ihr müsst halt irgendwie
dann auch mal LTE 99% der Fläche ab das wär doch mal was,
weil 100 Megabit habe ich auch mit LTE ehrlich.
Hatten wir ja auch in der letzten Sendungen zu Genüge diskutiert komme jetzt zu einem Thema dass mir sehr viel wichtiger,
ist am der digitalpakt der digitalpakt großes Thema,
es geht um die Frage ob wir nun da das obwohl das Ceran noch nicht durchschritten ist vielleicht Kindern seine Besichtigung,
im Rahmen ihrer Schullaufbahn ermöglichen wollen oder ob wir die Existenz des Internet solange wie möglich vor ihnen geheim halten stellt sich raus wer soll das bezahlen.
Und,
die Idee die letztes kopiert wird seit längerer Zeit ist hier könnte doch der Bund den Ländern Geld zuschießen auf dass sie,
das in die Bildungsinfrastruktur investieren können.
Denn in Deutschland ist ja ein föderaler Staat über bestimmte Bereiche haben die Länder weitergehende Hoheit und Bildung ist Ländersache.
Ist auch der Grund für die durchaus unterschiedlichen Schulsysteme die wir in Deutschland in deutschen Bundesländern haben und auch die unterschiedliche Qualität.
Die da mitunter in Studien festgestellt wird zwischen den Bundesländern.
Jetzt war die Idee wär doch mal schön wenn der Hund fünf Milliarden,
in die Schulen Pumpen könnte also Bundesregierung sagt hier fünf Milliarden das ist also um das mal eine Perspektive zu setzen 5 Milliarden das ist eine zehntel Bankenrettung.
Die war durch 50er Jahren nur so um zu sehen wie wo die Prioritäten liegen.
Und die waren 50 Milliarden die Waren innerhalb von einer Woche klar.
Bitte wer das ist ja antiproportionalen ajeli wenige kleiner der Betrag der zu länger brauchst du um den zu verhandeln.
Und die Bedingung diese gesagt haben ist okay die Länder müssten müsste dafür 10% zuschießen das Geld soll für Laptops Notebooks Tablets ausgegeben werden
die Dateninfrastruktur zur Vernetzung von Schulgebäuden soll dadurch gefordert werden WLAN an Schulen Lernplattform Kommunikationsplattform Schulserver interaktive Tafel und anderes also schon so ein bisschen infrastrukturförderung
für die Schule ab dem 1. Januar soll die Kohle fließen Problem das wäre.
Grundgesetzwidrig denn der Grundgesetz Artikel,
104c sagt der Bund kann den Ländern Finanzhilfen für das gesamtstaatlich für gesamtstaatlich bedeutsame Investitionen der finanzschwachen Gemeinden da man Gemeindeverbände im Bereich der kommunalen,
Bildungsinfrastruktur gewähren Artikel 104b Absatz 2 und 3 gilt entsprechend der soll der Muster für geändert.
Und die Änderungs Formulierung ist der Bund kann den Ländern zur Sicherstellung der Qualität und der Leistungsfähigkeit des Bildungswesen Finanzhilfen,
für gesamtstaatlich bedeutsame Investitionen sowie mit diesem verbundene besondere unmittelbare Kosten der Länder und Gemeinden Gemeindeverbände im Bereich der kommunalen Bildungsinfrastruktur gewähren Artikel 104b Absatz 2,
sat 1 bis 5 und Absatz 3 gilt entsprechend.
Soweit wäre das auch noch okay gewesen jetzt haben sie nur in diese Grundgesetzänderung noch ein paar andere mit reingemogelt,
entscheidend war in den de beginnt in diesem digitalpakt wo es mittelfristig gesagt wurde ja im Rahmen der digitalpakt Sachen müssen die Länder 10% zu schießen im weiteren Verlauf,
würden aber das geändert werden.
Dass sie sich bis zu dass sie sich zu 50% an solchen Investitionen beteiligen müssen nämlich in Artikel 104b,
die Mittel des Bundes sind in jeweils gleicher Höhe durch Landesmittel für den entsprechenden Investitionsbereich zu ergänzen das heißt sie sagen jetzt für die digitalpakt 90/10 insgesamt im Grundgesetz steht aber 50/50.
Und jetzt hast du die sehr skurrile Situation dass mehrere Bundesländer sich gegen diese Grundgesetzänderung sperren und damit auch gegen die Ermöglichung
ist digitalpakt und das wird heute diskutiert der Bundesrat soll dann am 14. Dezember
über diese Grundgesetzänderung entscheiden und jetzt hast du einerseits die Länder sagen ja wir wollen aber keine einheits Bundespolitik andererseits die Länder die sagen,
wir finden diese diese 50% Erhöhung das ist nicht das worüber wir uns geeinigt haben und jetzt scheint tatsächlich die Gefahr aktuell zu bestehen
dass diese Idee dieses digitalpakt eben am 14. Dezember im Bundesrat scheitern könnte einfach nur weil sie gedacht haben also wenn schon mal irgendwie Bundes
Grundgesetzänderung ist da können wir gleich noch ein paar mehr rein reinschieben.
Sehr skurril heute war heute morgen war in Deutschland. Ein Vertreter des der Kultusministerkonferenz,
der auch kaum in der Lage war dieses dort zu erklären weil die,
Meinungsverschiedenheiten eben über diese Grundgesetzänderung gehen und nicht über den digitalpakt,
der digitalpakt aber eigentlich das ist vorüber sich alle einig sind weil die Grundgesetzänderung die dafür notwendig ist eben
nicht unbedingt mit dem übereinstimmen was in digitalpakt ist sondern teilweise eben etwas anderes ich weiß auch nicht
ehrlich gesagt um wie die Grundgesetzänderung hier richtig oder falsch ist Grundgesetzänderung sind ein weites Feld mit und mit weitreichenden Konsequenzen dem,
dem ich mich nicht gewachsen fühle dafür gibt es hoffentlich die entsprechenden Expertinnen und Experten.
Die so etwas beurteilen aber ich wäre froh,
wenn wir diese bescheidenen fünf Milliarden mal langsam in die Schulen schieben könnten.
Ja ich habe nicht so viel Hoffnung dass diese fünf Milliarden viel bringen weil diese ganze wir kaufen jetzt mal Tablets und so weiter Nummer vor allem halt ICE komplett raus lässt das meiner Meinung nach viel wichtiger ist nämlich die entsprechende Ausbildung von Lehrern und Support.
Problem natürlich klar.
Und da wird dann dieser ganze Hardware Müll deren rumsteht auch nicht viel helfen also von daher grundsätzlich bin ich ja schon der Auffassung,
Meinung will ich gerade gar nicht mal sagen weil ich da ehrlich gesagt nicht so ein richtig qualifizierte Meinung habe aber das Land
bremst sich mit dieser föderalen Bildungsgeschichte doch enorm aus also ich weiß nicht wirklich warum wir sechzehn verschiedene Ansätze fahren müssen die alle irgendwie für sich viel zu klein sind um wirklich effizient vorangetrieben werden zu können
das scheint mir eher.
Eine Beschränkung zu sein die uns nicht wirklich voranbringt insofern werden vielleicht mal Grundgesetzänderung ganz sinnvoll aber man sieht schon die Kleinsten scheitern an den Ländern weil die einfach Angst haben,
alles weggenommen.
Haben diese Sache mit den desmangles natürlich eigentlich an der Kompetenz und Ausbildung der Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die stimmt natürlich andererseits fehlt es den auch an Anreiz,
Infrastruktur und Unterstützung um sich da mal weiterzuentwickeln ja so ein Henne-Ei-Problem gewissermaßen,
die können kein dicken digitalen Unterricht führen weil
die Schule nicht dafür ausgerüstet ist die Situationen dafür nicht
bestehen das zu tun und wenn jetzt die Infrastruktur dann einmal da ist dann wären sie einen Anreiz haben und zu dem Zeitpunkt wenn diese Infrastruktur dann völlig veraltet ist dann steht sie zumindest,
soweit dass sie damit irgendwie was können.
Ja ich meinen anreis hätten sie dann vielleicht aber damit hätten sie immer noch keine Mittel um Leute einzustellen und dann sieht das ja also wir sehen das ja zumindest hier in Berlin ist einfach,
vom Personalstamm her so prekär das soll ja noch nicht mal in der Lage bist durchgehend Unterricht zu gewährleisten und das sind die,
erst im fünften Schritt dabei neue Stellen einzuführen die sich ausschließlich um eine digitale.
So oder so.
Irgendwo muss der mal anfangen gemacht werden und wir sind sie sich für gute deutsche gehört im Moment dabei den mal wieder,
nur mit bedenken,
und ihr welchen Ablenkungen am Ende zu verkacken ich die werden sich da schon ewig zusammenraufen aber es geht auch hier nennen offenbar nicht ohne größeren,
grundgesetzlichen Flurschaden.
Die wollen die wollen die Kohle halt haben aber sie wollen sich halt jetzt auch nicht reindrücken lassen das alles was vom Boden kommt zur Hälfte gegenfinanziert werden muss können wir verstehen.
Dann erreichte mich ein Hilferuf von Robert tibbo Robert,
tätowierter ich war eigentlich sonst immer T-Bone aber die müssen in den Filmen wurde er tebo ausgesprochen dich in dir noch mal dazu angeschaut habe das ist der Anwalt von Snowden in Hongkong.
Der erinnern uns Norden war das denn 20.13 ist alles schon wieder so lange her.
Wann war der am Flughafen von Hongkong gestrandet oder in Hongkong gestrandet hatte sich zwar darüber Gedanken gemacht dass er mit
Glenn greenwald und Laura poitras da indem,
wie ist das Hotel Mirage oder Mira oder sowas in dem Hotel da irgendwie seinen Film macht und dass er sich ein Hoodie über den Kopf zieht und über die über den Laptop wenn er sein Passwort eingibt aber hatte sich nicht irgendwie darüber Gedanken gemacht was empfindest EMA
durch ist musste also irgendwie aus diesem Hotel raus.
Geschleust werden und in Hongkong untertauchen und es war Robert der ihm dann dabei
geholfen hat das zu tun indem er ihn nämlich bei,
Staatenlosen in Hongkong untergebracht hat inspir namentlich Vanessa zu tun nadica Ajit und deren Kindern,
die aus mehr oder weniger aus Sri Lanka und einem weiteren Land Nepal glaube ich kommen.
Und sich dort in Hongkong,
als geflüchtete aufhielten und Robert Klienten war alles also als Menschenrechtsanwalt natürlich bis mit solchen Fällen auch beschäftigt hier eben der Asylantrag dieser Menschen.
Die Asylanträge dieser Menschen und.
Dort hat er daneben Snowden ich glaube für insgesamt zwei Wochen versteckt dann wurde irgendwie geklärt das Norden aus Hongkong ausreißt wenn ich mich nicht täusche dann eben in Russland landet.
Und diese,
Menschen die in der versteckt haben das wurde erstmal geheim gehalten dann hat aber Oliver Stone diesen Film Snowden,
verfilmt indem er ja dann auch.
Diese Szenen dass Robert ihn daraus schleust und das ist sondern eben von diesem geflüchteten oder da eben auf längere Zeit versorgt und versteckt wird.
Dass das da drin vorkommt und dann haben die sich entschieden naja in dem Moment wo wir das tun wird im Prinzip so oder so die Suche nach den losgehen dann machen wir lieber die Flucht nach vorne überholen die Medien und die Ermittler.
In diesem Bereich und release and diese Geschichte.
Das war bei einem 33c 3 zusammen mit Amnesty International und im Handelsblatt Reporter eben der der Vortrag die Antholz stories,
after Snowden refugees und kurz nach dieser Präsentation ging es dann eigentlich los dass die Polizei von Sri Lanka in Hongkong auf einmal auftauchte,
und dass die Hongkonger Einreisebehörde plötzlich,
all deren Fälle die normalerweise über Jahre hingezogen werden.
Zur zur Entscheidung brachte und damit halt irgendwie auch gegen Robert,
eine ganze Menge Robert eine ganze Menge Probleme schaffte sie haben dann wurden verschiedene anonyme Beschwerden an die,
und das Board of lawyers oder sowas geschrieben also quasi die ich weiß gar nicht wie man sowas nennt ne.
Rechtsanwaltskammer.
Rechtsanwaltskammer an die Rechtsanwaltskammer Beschwerden an die Rechtsanwaltskammer eingereicht und.
Ja die unmittelbare Deportation eigentlich dieser Menschen in die Wege geleitet nach Sri Lanka wo ihn aber halt die die Folter droht und es ist inzwischen so,
problematisch geworden das jetzt auch Robert Hongkong verlassen musste die,
refugees diese üblicherweise
referenzierten haben ihn dann noch zum Flughafen begleitet und er ist jetzt eben aus Hongkong mehr oder weniger geflohen und ist da jetzt quasi behördlicher Willkür und Gängeleien ausgesetzt
ja ist es sowas wie du hast 50 Fälle und alle deine 50 Fälle bringen wir jetzt in den nächsten 14 Tagen zu Verhandlungen ja da seid kein Zufall
nenne das ist etwas um diesen Anwalt eben zu stressen und danach hätte sozusagen ja hör mal du hast diese Fälle ja hier mehrmals verzögert und so du machst deine Arbeit nicht.
Den geht's jetzt an den an den Kragen gewissermaßen deswegen ein sein Hilferuf weiterhin.
Gibt es also das Problem was machen wir jetzt mit diesem refugees die haben jetzt Asyl in Kanada beantragt.
Kanada ist Robert Geburtsland also es Canaria und,
für Kanada ist das natürlich jetzt auch ne heiße Kartoffel ne die könnten natürlich mein was denen in Sri Lanka widerfahren ist
ist relativ Teile sind Folteropfer relativ klar dass das eigentlich für jede für jeden Asylantrag
ganz ganz einfach die,
Bedingungen erfüllt aber Kanada Daisy natürlich auch so so dieses Noten Leute ne wollen wir die irgendwie.
Wollen wir uns dieses Problem irgendwie eintreten wenn wir da eh gerade so einen Schreihals nebenan haben ja der für den kleinsten Furz eben finde eine diplomatische Krise vom Zaun bricht ja also,
schwierig schwierig schwierig gleichzeitig haben die ungefähr,
für alle Ernstfall für diese vier Personen und deren Kindern da hast du sowas wie sechseinhalb 1000 € Dollar im Monat.
Lebens Erhaltungskosten und auch die Liege Kost also die die Kosten für die Anwälte,
mit Reisen und sonstigen sind jetzt irgendwie mal locker auf 50000 gekommen das ist obwohl die pro bono Arbeiten der propone arbeiten heißt ja nicht dass du jeden jeden Flug jede Reise,
alles kostenlos macht sondern dass du selber keine persönlichen persönliches Geld aus sie sind auch mal locker 50000.
Dollar zusammengekommen das heißt sie brauchen irgendwie jetzt mal so knapp kurz um,
die Berufung gegen ihre Deportation einzulegen mal eben so was wie 250.000,
Dollar unter uns unter anderem deshalb weil die ihre die legalite Organisationen aus Hongkong nicht mehr zahlen wer weiß warum wir das nicht mehr tun die werden wahrscheinlich auch ihre Briefe bekommen haben.
Es gibt mehrere Disziplinarstrafen also die Polizei ist irgendwie hinter ihm her ist einfach.
Das sind so die Dinge die halt natürlich dann Menschen widerfahren.
Die hier in dem Fall nichts anderes gemacht haben als den Menschen dessen ja muss man ganz einfach sein Leben in Gefahr war und der von den mächtigsten Geheimdienste der Welt gesucht wurde mal eben zu verstecken das nehmen die.
Verschiedenen Staaten beim da gerne mal übel.
Insofern wir verlinken die beiden Torx die beide sehr sehenswert sind natürlich,
Norden sich auch letztes Jahr wie bekannt ist da noch mal per Videokonferenz zu gemeldet es gibt die Seite for the refugees Dotcom ohmann also spenden kann.
Und haben von der National Posten von dem Standard mehrere Artikel zu diesem Thema die ich euch gerne an.
Herzlichen möchte und das ist deshalb wichtig weil das jetzt eben paar Jahre her ist,
und weil das jetzt eben diese Menschen ruiniert und diesen Anwalt stark unter Druck setzt und weil das eben gerade nicht mehr Thema Nummer eins ist genau deswegen ist es wichtig da jetzt als Zivilgesellschaft eben auch beizustehen.
Und diese Leute nicht jetzt paar Jahre später allein zu lassen wo sie jetzt eben die Quittung dafür kriegen,
damals für Menschenrechte eingetreten zu sein das ist wichtig in zu sondern paar Jahre später wo,
ist auch zunehmend schwierig wird dafür noch Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen weil alle sagen Astrotreff für die haben doch beim 33c 3 gesehen beim 34c 3 gesehen und genau deshalb ist vorbei jetzt auch wieder beim 32 C3,
war das Licht bleiben wir bei den schlechten Nachrichten ne wir haben heute.
Unsere Spezialität.
Wäre heute auch eine gute Nachricht danach die kommt danach da könnt ihr ja schon mal Rätsel was mit die gute Nachricht ist.
Bei uns häufig behandelt das Unternehmen NSA und sein Produkt Pegasus.
Ein israelisches Unternehmen dass ein Smartphone Trojaner herstellt.
Auch dieser die I erkennen und die Analyse dieses Trojaners war wenn ich mich nicht täusche vor zwei oder drei Jahren beim Kongress Thema da hatten wir,
die Leute vom citizenlab und so die diese Analysen gemacht haben.
Und diese nSo group also ein israelisches Unternehmen das einen Staatstrojaner verkauft,
und,
wir wissen inzwischen dass dieser insbesondere im Rahmen saudi-arabischer Interessen eingesetzt wird nicht nur aber eben auch zwar gegen,
Angestellte von Amnesty International und die eine Nachricht bekommen haben wo ihn quasi ja ich sag mal so ein clickbait gelegt wurden es gebe jetzt irgendwas über die,
Saudi Boot die Botschaft der Saudi ist in Washington DC einen Link den Sie sich unbedingt anschauen sollten und da ist dann eben wenn du da drauf klickst kommt dann eben der Exploit und die die Installation dieser Schatz auf der auf deinem Handy.
Die EM ist die Angestellten an das damals gemerkt dass eben zu Analyse gegeben,
sie MST klagt jetzt gerade gegen die oder bemüht sich in Israel die
Exportlizenz nach Saudi-Arabien eben einstellen zu lassen wegen der Menschenrechtsverletzungen die Saudi-Arabien mit dieser Hilfe mithilfe dieser Software begeht Israel hat das verweigert.
Und jetzt kommt der Knüller es gibt einen Menschen namens Oma Abul Aziz und dessen Smartphone wurde ebenfalls investiert infiziert,
und dann investigated es nicht investiert und,
außerdem gibt's noch eine also neben der Person von msitc noch jeden Mann mit dem Namen jaja asiri die eben auch diese,
Infektionen auf ihren Smartphones harten und das citizenlab eben die kanadische,
Untersuchungs Einrichtung unter Professor Ronald Deibert die sich eben zur Forschung.
In diesem in diesem Bereich der Forschung in diesem Bereich verschrieben fühlt und,
da immer wieder mit den Staatstrojaner Analysen auffällt die haben sich eben diese Infektion bei Oma abula sie's untersucht.
Und dort eben eine Infektion mit Pegasus festgestellt so warum berichte ich da jetzt noch einmal drüber,
naja Oma Abul Aziz hat sehr viel mit Jamal khashoggi oder khashoggi ich weiß nicht genau wie man das ausspricht hat 60.
Ist mir auch unklar.
Die Amis sagen cacaci aber die Amis sind jetzt nicht dafür bekannt Dinge richtig auszusprechen,
ich sage jetzt für diese Sendung khashoggi weil das garantiert falsch ist und dann könnte alle sagen normal falsch gemacht.
Abdul-aziz Oma abdul-aziz hat also mit dem Jamaica schottka Schoggi Schoggi ja doch recht okay dann sage ich dann sagen die Amis das doch richtig kann schodzi.
Kommuniziert relativ viel und die haben über WhatsApp kommuniziert weil die Sachen ja WhatsApp ist ja hier,
in der Ferne verschlüsselt dummerweise hat jetzt dieser Oma abdul-aziz eben diesen Staatstrojaner von and DNS Aukrug drauf.
Und in den Gesprächen haben sie sich tatsächlich darüber unterhalten naja im weitesten Sinne.
Eine Untergrundorganisation zu gründen abdul-aziz nennt das die electronic Army und sie sprechen da tatsächlich also die Begriffe die sie verwenden sind relativ.
Solar Regierungs manchmal erkennt da drin sehr klar ihre Regierungs Feindlichkeit der khashoggi.
Kritisiert MBS also den Mohammed bin Salman will ich jetzt auch immer nur MBS.
Bin zweimal heißt es drin oder bin.
Bin Salman Mohammed bin Salman.
Ja freilich MBSR der ist allgemein bekannt Mohammed bin Salman der Kronprinz von Saudi Arabien mehr oder weniger eben derjenige der gerade den Ton angibt.
Und karczocha djamaikata Shoji äußert sich sehr kritisch über den und jetzt.
Liegt eben die Vermutung nahe dass unter Umständen eine der Rollen.
Das Jamaica Georgi in das Konsulat in Israel geladen wurde und es dort eben offenbar eine Auseinandersetzung mit Todesfolge gab dass dieses.
Israel.
Entschuldigung in meine Güte in Istanbul das ist jetzt wirklich jetzt jetzt hörst du passt auf er.
In Istanbul geladen wurde das da eben auch dieser Staatstrojaner nicht weit weg war und,
jetzt klagt der Oma abdul-aziz in Tel Aviv,
eben führt gegen den Bruch der NSA im internationalen Völkerrecht indem sie diese Staatstrojaner Software eben gegen eindeutige nicht Demokratien,
verkauft haben und sie dort eben auch zum Einsatz kam zur und zwar im Rahmen von eindeutig Menschenrechtsverletzungen.
Das ist weißt du da da wird dann irgendwie.
Mike klar was das eben für Unternehmen sind die solche Software herstellen und mit welchen,
Staaten die Geschäfte machen erst also eigentlich völlig klar dass Israel,
eigentlich dieses Unternehmen sofort zur Rechenschaft ziehen muss für diese Menschenrechtsverletzungen völlig klar dass diese Export Lizenzen,
nicht infrage kommen das ist eigentlich auch für jede Demokratie völlig klar dass man mit diesem Unternehmen keine Geschäfte machen möchte.
Buntes wir können froh sein dass wir sowas wieder citizenlab haben wir können froh sein dass wir Leute wie Amnesty International haben die da eben drauf achten diese Dinge untersuchen.
Und diese Skandal Skandale an die Öffentlichkeit bringen und das ist das worüber wir diskutieren wenn wir in Deutschland eben sagen,
lasst es bitte sein mit solchen,
mit der überhaupt die Ermächtigungsgrundlagen zum Einsatz solcher Software zu schaffen lass es bitte sein mit diesen Unternehmen zusammenzuarbeiten denen Geld zu geben und man kann hier auch von,
Israel eindeutig verlangen dass sie solche Software nicht auch noch fördern.
Fahnen aus ihrem eigenen Feind da das verstehe ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht.
Das ist alles sehr sehr,
besorgniserregend und dieser ganze Georgie Skandal ist sowieso besorgniserregend wie auch die internationale Staatengemeinschaft damit oben geht das hier wirklich einfach mal Journalisten getötet werden,
über die Reaktion von Donald Trump Romy leuchten nicht zu diskutieren.
Nee aber auch Europa ist sich mal wieder nicht einig und ich habe halt nicht eine klare Position zu beziehen es ist so ein bisschen.
Saudi-Arabien kann sich echt eine ganze Menge erlauben und das ist sehr erstaunlich wie alle dazu die Fresse halten.
Da ist echt eine Menge Kohle im Spiel das ist nicht nur so ein bisschen sondern ist einfach gibt glaube ich kaum kaum eine Quelle von mir Geld,
für alles als Saudi-Arabien.
Ohne dass man sich für irgendwas groß rechtfertigen müsste zum ist nicht in Saudi-Arabien da wird halt einfach nach Gutsherrenart hätte ich es fast gesagt nach Scheich nach Art des Scheichs,
gehandelt und so läufts dann halt.
Kann man sich nur als große Warnung im Leben gelten lassen.
Komme zu der gute Nachricht das ist die gute Nachricht fügte guckt überrascht.
Das findest du es dir gut.
Die gute Nachricht ist Peak Facebook es ist vorbei wir erleben es noch.
Eine optimistische Deutung ja das ja das würde ich schon sagen also ich meine Scheiße sind die ja schon lange.
Aber jetzt geht sie dann.
Immer irgendwas nicht bin ich ja auch für bekannt was ich dir geht's vielleicht nicht anders.
Du bist dafür bekannt dass Facebook scheiße ist.
Nee ich bin was heißt cand also keine Ahnung also ich habe mich.
Kamin zu mir nicht dran erinnern dass ich mich schon irgendwie mal groß positiv zu facebook geäußert hätte das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt indem begründet was dann letztlich in bei rauskam,
ich habe sie nicht primär als Bedrohung des Weltfriedens gesehen sondern fand halt einfach erstmal nur so an sich verwirrend und uninteressant aber das hat natürlich was damit zu tun dass ich so als alter nerd,
bitte Angebot nicht so viel anfangen konnte habe aber schon gesehen dass das eben für viele Leute durchaus,
großer Spaß zu sein scheint und dass sie da mit großer Freude ihre Daten reingeworfen haben weil Facebook halt einfach.
Bedarf abgedeckt hat der der offensichtlich da war in das Internet zu dem Zeitpunkt,
so noch nicht bedienen konnte das ist sicherlich mit Fehlfunktion diese haben immer noch so na ja aber trotzdem,
gab's ja schon immer genug Kritik daran,
und jetzt haben wir gesehen wie in letzter Zeit Facebook doch ganz schön ins Schlingern kommt vor allem in der öffnen,
Kriegsschauplatz nach dem anderen wird da eröffnet erinnern uns die ganze Diskussion um die Beeinflussung der US-Wahl da wurden halt,
Werbeanzeigen Verkauf verkauft an dubiose russische Unternehmen die das dann halt wie wir dann später erfahren haben mit.
Profildaten zielgerichtet an bestimmte Leute ausgeliefert haben sozusagen jeder kriegt er da seine eigene direkt auf,
ihn oder sie zugeschnittene übersteigerte Falschmeldung wie es denn so mit dem Planeten gerade so läuft und warum man deswegen Donald Trump wählen sollte.
Und das scheint ja auch ganz gut funktioniert zu haben zumindest hat es dann eben diesen TippingPoint erreicht oder neben tatsächlich Trump Florida und noch zwei andere Staaten Wisconsin und Ohio gewinnen Konto um daneben mit einer.
Stimmen Minderheit Präsident zu werden dann kam ja später noch raus die ganze ein Beeinflussungen im Rahmen vom
brexit Votum Cambridge analytica als Unternehmen was mit Verbindungen alle Richtungen vor allem auch
Verbindung in die Republikaner sehen in USA hier ganz massiv eben diese Daten da gearbeitet hat und es eben auf Facebook hier eine Rolle hatte zunächst einmal dadurch dass sie ihre ab East
geöffneten hatten und das eben auch viele
viele hatten wir hatten damals wurde ja vor allem dieser Zugriff auf Freunde von Freunden aktiv ausgenutzt und mit solchen clickbaits Apps auf Facebook da halt möglichst viele Leute mit reinzuziehen hier dein
digitalife und wir bewerten mal wieder eine Welt aussieht und lieg hier und jeder der hatten teilgenommen hat quasi alle seine Facebook-Freunde
auch noch mit ausgeliefert später das hat mir ja auch schon mal diskutiert gab's denn diese Funktion obwohl sie offiziell abgeschaltet war,
trotzdem noch mal weil es einfach ein entsprechenden Fehler in dem facebook-code gab und man sich eigentlich nur in diesem ich bin jetzt mal meinen freund Modus schalten muss oder irgendjemand anderes und dann.
Hat man nicht mit den view auf sich selbst sein eben auch den view auf alles andere von dieser Person damit lag auch wieder alles offen also.
Das ganze steigert sich jetzt immer noch weiter,
und vor allem wird die Diskussion um Facebook immer wilder und facebook wird offensichtlich richtig nervös das geht ja mittlerweile soweit das jetzt sogar schon mal hätte das glaube ich vor,
weniger,
wenigen ja noch nicht für möglich gehalten oder vielleicht auch vor wenigen Monaten nicht mittlerweile tatsächlich so eine Diskussion um eine datenschutz-grundverordnung also eine sprechende privacy Regelung
im Stil von der dsgvo in den USA aktiv diskutiert wird der neugewählte Kongress dürfte da sicherlich deutlich empfänglicher sein für solche Debatten jetzt wo die Demokraten da wieder den,
die Mehrheit zurückgewonnen haben oder demnächst zurück bekommen haben werden und ja noch nicht im Amt geht erst im Januar los.
Dazu kommt dass für Facebook die Userzahlen rückläufig sind in Europa also hier scheint es auch einfach zu nehmen um populär zu werden man sieht das an dieser
total übersteigerten Plakatierung von Facebook überall da wo sie die ganze Zeit erzählen wie toll sie doch eigentlich sind und ZWS ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm ist das wird ja auf mich schon recht panisch
auch in den USA stornieren wohl die USA Stein ihren die Nutzerzahlen sie haben noch Wachstum in Schwellenländern aber da,
sind halt nicht die Leute die viel Geld ausgeben und Leute die viel Geld auswählen geben sind für Facebook wichtig denn Mama nichts vor das Businesshotel heißt Werbung und.
Werbung bedeutet Leuten die Geld ausgeben entsprechende Informationen zu führen und wenn halt entweder diese Leute nicht mehr zugeführt werden können,
oder die Leute kein Geld haben die dazu geführt werden dann funktioniert natürlich Facebook auch nicht mehr so gut zumindest finanziell nicht so,
das ganze wird er noch angereichert durch die Wahrnehmung dass es sich halt bei facebook um einen zunehmenden Maße zersetzenden Körper handelt nicht also das hier fake-news und sonstiger Trash sich einfach und Nazi Horden
dort einfach breit machen
und das ist natürlich für Werbekunden auch nicht so toll weil die wollen natürlich auch ein gewisses Image waren und auch dieses Image geht weggibt da um Fragen die sagen dass wir nur noch 22% der US-Bürger da Vertrauen haben in Facebook,
andere Unternehmen kommt darum die zu mir aufs Doppelte ist ja sowieso immer so interessanten in unserer Wahrnehmung.
Das heißt mehr Leute wählen Trump als Leute Facebook vertrauen.
Haben gewählt ja also ich meine seine Zeit aber seine seine Zustimmungsrate liegt ja auch so in dem.
Nee die ist im wobei 38.
30 % also ich glaube das kann man jetzt nicht so richtig vergleichen finde ich aber trotzdem bemerkenswert weil es ja grundsätzlich in der amerikanischen Kultur so ist das ja Unternehmen hatte Dich mehr vertraut wird als dem Start.
Bei uns ist es ja genau anders.
Deswegen haben sie ja auch einen erfolgreichen Unternehmer als Präsident.
Das hat auch damit zu tun so also dieser dieser dieser Glaube an die eigene Wirtschaft und an an die Unabhängigkeit vom Staat also Status immer noch,
immer noch das was irgendwie Joghurt die wollen unsere Sklaven wegnehmen.
Bin noch so dazu erodiert auch
innerhalb von Facebook ganz offensichtlich hat die Loyalität der Mitarbeiter gelitten das mag an einigen Dingen liegen
fallende Aktienkurse tragen dass ich ja dich dazu bei weil es läuft ja gerade nicht so gut für Facebook generell der ganze Text dogs Markt ist in USA etwas volatil geworden Facebook sieht da besonders schlecht aus da für viele Mitarbeiter
Aktienoptionen ja Teil der Bezahlung sind bringt es dazu bei dass sie dann nicht unbedingt das bekommen was Sie sich vielleicht vorgestellt haben und man merkt es gibt also in zunehmendem Maße leaks,
nebenbei droht dann Zuckerberg auch noch gleich Mitarbeiter mit Entlassung wenn sie mit Journalisten sprechen also da ist so der der Haussegen mehr als schief,
trotz alledem kommt immer mehr raus und wird immer mehr darüber berichtet wie es denn nun tatsächlich abgeht E-Mails werden bekannt gegeben ist,
in dem Zusammenhang kam es z.b. raus dass nach dem George Soros,
das Feindbild aller Verschwörungstheoretiker Hardcore rechten.
Das ist gerade was die umdrehen für skurrile.
Ist ein Zauber der da gemacht wird es ist wirklich unfassbar also der ist so sollte der Inbegriff des Satans ja dabei ist der sich auch aus wahrscheinlich echt einer der wenigen die viel Geld haben und trotzdem noch irgendwie alle beisammen haben,
durch sauersteig geworden die Mama gegen das Pfund spekuliert hat
und hat mit seinem Geld ein ganz interessantes Imperium aufgebaut aber im Gegensatz zu anderen die sich dann halt nur die Yachten zur Vermietung gekauft haben hat sauer schalt sehr viel Geld in
Universitäten gesteckt seine eigene Universität da gegründet er unterstützt viele.
Organisationen die sich um Recht und Freiheit und offene Gesellschaft kümmernitztal.
Sshd von day.
Open society Foundation also man kann er sagen,
die Welt braucht mehr so Leute wie George Soros.
Aber er ist natürlich sind eben bei allen Leuten die die Welt lieber brennen sehen der totale Feind weil halt auch noch Jude ist und dann passt das natürlich wunderbar hier Bild der jüdischen Weltverschwörung.
Facebook ist jetzt auch mit dabei weil nachdem sich so rasch auf dem in Davos
in einer Rede kritisch über Facebook und wohl auch Google geäußert hat und meinte es wäre eine Bedrohung der Gesellschaft und man müsste hier mal Überregulierung Nachdenken
sind gleich aktiv geworden und haben dann irgendwie seine finanziellen Interessen mal abgegraben das entsprechende E-Mails bei rausgekommen wo
die Sheryl Sandberg halt mal da die Mitarbeiter hat investigieren lassen wie denn da sein Interessenlage sein könnte
und später hat dann Zuckerberg auch noch eine PA Firma engagiert die aus dem republikanischen Umfeld kommt define as public airfares heißt der Laden und da eine Kampagne gestartet um daneben
Diesel gewonnen Informationen dann wiederum andere Listen zustecken hier,
was ist orange hier alles für Interessen hat und verkleidete gegen uns wetter.de es ist ja hier um,
einer Verschwörung passt natürlich wunderbar ins Bild dementsprechend muss ich Facebook jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit auch mit Antisemitismus Vorwürfen,
auseinandersetzen es geht richtig rund und als wenn das alles noch nicht genug wäre,
ist natürlich auch Großbritannien dabei den Fall rund um den brexit betrug weiter aufzuarbeiten und zieht hier ganz neue Register da wurde jetzt eine eine Unternehmen.
Ein britisches Unternehmen was auch auf Facebook Apps entwickelt hat six four three sisters und die haben irgendwie alt auch so alberne Sachen gemacht wie hier suche.
Leicht bekleidete Damen in deiner Facebook Umgebung ist hütterer
wo Leute drauf rum gekriegt haben und dann eben auch das alte Spiel gespielt haben mit gibt doch mal hier da einen Zugriff auf Freunde
frei und die App hat hat auch dieses Freunde von Freunden Feature benutzt und nachdem Facebook dann aber Dich gemacht hatten gesagt hat so nee das stellen wir euch jetzt nicht mehr zur Verfügung weil es ist jetzt hier zu heiß haben die dann dagegen geklagt,
und im Rahmen dieser Klage sind dann wiederum Dokumente Amtsgericht gekommen und die wurden jetzt
öffentlich und daraus wurde dann nämlich wiederum bekannt dass Facebook obwohl sie diesen api-zugriff abgeschaltet haben bestimmten Teilnehmern hier sind genannt Airbnb und Netflix sehr wohl diesen Zugriff noch gestattet haben,
mit anderen Worten alles,
Lüge und facebook ist schwer unter Dauerfeuer und hat schon bessere Zeiten.
Ja ist doch schön niederbrennen.
Fragt sich nur was danach kommt aber in gewisser Hinsicht kann man auch mal an dieser Stelle feststellen datenschutz-grundverordnung und der,
hot währende Widerstand gegen das Geschäftsgebaren scheint ihr was zu bringen ja also das ist.
Man kann schon regeln aufzwingen wann muss ich lange darüber unterhalten wie diese Regeln sein sollen ist sicherlich noch nicht alles,
in trockenen Tüchern was man da eigentlich wollen würde aber die Entwicklung der letzten Jahre sind eigentlich ganz positiv hinein.
Auf die Idee ob das jetzt anders auf Facebook jetzt an der dsgvo zugrunde geht oder einfach daran dass der dass der Zuckerwerk halt irgendwie offenbar auch nicht.
Ganz so sagen wir mal.
Na dann nicht so wollte ich es nicht verstanden wissen.
Eine reife zu fehlende.
Das kommt noch dazu aber es halt auch einfach dieses Geschäftsmodell mit wir nehmen eure Daten und machen was wir wollen das findet langsam ein Ende.
Dafür auch er darf das wäre das wäre zu da dann würde ich mitgehen das wäre zu hoffen da gibt's ein widerstanden zunehmende nicht nur politischen seine auch in der Gesellschaft und das das wäre sehr schön,
Facebook im Moment scheint tatsächlich mein du hast ja auch so andere Skurrilitäten von diesem,
Zuckerberg ein fetter irgendwie rüber nach Mountain nachnennen X4 wo sitzt wo sitzt Apple Cupertino streitet sich irgendwie mit dem Steve Jobs Tim Cook natürlich heute habe ich echt nett,
fährt nach Mountain View und streitet sich mit Steve Jobs ja.
News Google.
Das ist schön RTL NOW.
Dann kommt da irgendwie zurück hat sich mit dem Tim Cook gezankt und sagt ja zur Freunde wenn ich hier nur einen mit dem mit dem iPhone erwische ich will das jetzt alles Android Handys benutzt ne,
also ja wieso sollte das da merkt halt dass den Leuten unter Umständen ja der der strategische,
Weitblick für das Unternehmen und für ihre persönliche Rolle fehlt.
Und dass sie das wund dann wundert es mich nicht dass wenn jemand sowas macht dann wundert mich auch nicht wenn er vielleicht den Laden nicht ganz im Griff hat,
wenn dann da irgendwie vielleicht kommen immer wieder komische Sachen
hervortreten ob er davon wusste oder nicht ist dann auch wieder unklar also das sind so Anzeichen für einen unter Umständen nicht ganz gelungenen,
Führungsstil auch und wenn der führungs die nicht so ganz gelungen ist der muss sich auch nicht wundern wenn du unter Umständen wann die Organisation nicht mehr im Griff hast im Sinne von.
Auch den Leuten vertrauen kannst das dass du vielleicht auch eine Kultur in dem Unternehmen hast das.
Dass die Leute deine Vision teilen ja weil wenn der Chef auf einmal reinkommt und sei übrigens hier heute mit dem Tim Cook Mittag gegessen ist ein a******** ihr verkauft jetzt alle eure Handys.
Oder oder am besten verkauft ihr die nicht sondern macht die kaputt ich meine dann weißt du dass der dass der auch in wahrscheinlich in Meetings oder in strategiebesprechung oder in in der generellen Führung des Unternehmens im Zweifelsfall nicht,
dringend geistig präsent ist oder soll ich mal kalkulierbar ist indem,
wie er agiert und handelt es ist sehr farfetched aber.
Der spricht auf jeden Fall der Psychologe ich mache mir weniger Gedanken.
Bei mir hatte die ganze Zeit mit unterschiedlichen Unternhemen zu tun hat und dann merkst du das halt tatsächlich.
Aber ich will sagen auch andere Unternehmen haben mit der a******** Methode viel zu lange überlebt und leben wahrscheinlich auch immer noch woran es aber auch ihm fehlt und das,
würde ich auch in seiner eigenen Psychologie begründen wollen.
Er hat einfach diesen big für die Gesellschaft und das große Ganze nicht er hat da irgendwie gezündelt und hatte wollte da irgendwie seinen Universitäts Kinder machen und Viani
Mädchen ranzukommen oder was weiß ich was meine Motivation war dabei gemerkt.
Weil er die also seine seine Motivation war ja eher die hässlichen Menschen zu demütigen das war ja also muss man tatsächlich sagen hat ja gesagt diese auslöser waren ja nicht die schönen Menschen sondern dass er die hässlichen beleidigen und bloßstellen wollen.
Auf jeden Fall ist er in sehr jungen Jahren sehr erfolgreich und sehr einflussreich geworden und,
irgendwie nicht gut wenn du nicht mal in deinem Leben auch mal einen Moment der Demut verspürt hast und dann auf einmal.
Dir dann auch noch sozusagen die Welt ihre ihre ihre Daten und einen Einblick in ihr Innerstes bietet es aber keine.
Ja aber ich habe trotzdem kein Mitleid mit dem.
Ich habe Woche kein Mitleid mit ihm darum geht's mir auch garnicht seid einfach nur in London Drama dass es überhaupt so weit hat
kommen können uns hat ja nun wirklich enorme Auswirkungen gehabt ich würde jetzt nicht sagen Facebook allein ist schuld daran dass Donald Trump in der Welt ist dass es sicherlich ein vielfältiges Geflecht aber nichtsdestotrotz macht es schon ein riesen Unterschied
wo man seinem Unternehmen auch einem moralischen Grundausrichtung,
mit gibt und unten diese Verankerung einfach hat,
daraufhin seine Entscheidung fällt oder ob alles nur noch geprägt ist davon von ich komme mit allem durch ich kann machen was ich will bin sowieso der geilste was wollte ja.
Und das spielt auch insbesondere in dieser ganzen Valley Kultur durchaus eine Rolle er da,
das dein Unternehmen in irgendeiner Form eine positive Vision bietet.
Denke an dieses ganze don't be evil Theater mit Google denke an,
so etwas sieht als mein Apple hat ja auch irgendwie ne dieses wir machen Technologie für die Menschen mit denen irgendwie anders wir machen das besser ja das sind immer irgendwie so.
Das waren oder das sind Unternehmen die es schaffen für unterschiedliche Werte und Vorsprünge in in der Gesellschaft ihre Mitarbeiter,
mit Stolz zu füllen also ich arbeite bei Google dir,
machen irgendwie einfach wir machen das Mendes dass das Wissen der Menschheit irgendwie verfügbar wir sind nicht böse wir helfen euch ne wir sind die unzensierte Suchmaschine, gleich noch mal kurz zu dem Thema.
Sodass ich sie wie Google und Facebook konnte halt nie so wirklich damit überzeugen zu sein
wir bringen die Menschen zueinander ne wir bringen die Kommunikation wir connecten die Leute hier das war irgendwie dann versucht
dass ihr wieder ey die Menschheit zusammen aber es waren halt alle die da bei Facebook arbeiten was er im Zweifelsfall zu großen großen Teilen sehr begnadete Informatiker sind die wissen durchaus des Lichtes it for Facebook schon Internet gab er und die Kante,
konnte man glaube ich auch nie so wirklich von dieser,
von dieser Vision überzeugen dass man da mit Facebook möglich an was gutem arbeiten würde das ist glaube ich schon auch den Leuten die da sitzen.
Klar egal was du den noch alles irgendwie hören 5 infinite Vision gibst oder so.
Ja falls jemand von euch bei Facebook arbeitet bestimmt auch noch andere Unternehmen die ganzen passante.
Ich würde sagen Verlass das sinkende Schiff solange wie dieser Marke im Curriculum vita noch,
zeig mal entschuldbar ist ja am Ende ist das schwierig wenn man da zu lange geblieben ist dann ist er wird man irgendwann sagen soll sie haben da diese Lücke im Lebenslauf,
wo sie bis 20 20 bei facebook wann Visum sie eigentlich 2017 nicht den Absprung geschafft also.
Achte ich würde sagen 18 Grad noch.
18 Jahre sitzt zu mach den Absprung noch 18 ja.
Ja noch drei Wochen Zeit.
Ich würde sagen.
Wir stellen euch jetzt ein Ultimatum.
Als ihr Karriereberater würde ich ihn dazu raten unbedingt noch ein Absprung 20810 zu schaffen das sieht sonst einfach.
Das könnte schwierig werden.
Berufsberatung bei Logbuch net.
Gerade von uns Filme hier 40.
Grad werden.
Wenn es noch nicht läuft.
Tims, hiermit ich sehe an meinem schönen die.
Artikel 13 nein doch nicht.
Singend gesagt call bitte mit denn wenn wir schon bei Werten sind dann wollen wir auch mal ganz kurz eine Kurzmeldung vorgreifen die wir also eigentlich unter Kurzmeldung aber wenn man bei Unternehmenswerten sind dann müssen wir durch Aussagen und denke ich passt hier sehr gut,
Google.
Bei Google Ausgleich über Google werden jetzt die Google wie sicher die Google Angestellten nennen und die nennt sich Google als etwas Besonderes zu Google ja.
Ja die also Google du bist ein wenn du bei google aber ist bisschen Google das ist auch sehr schön dich wenn du wenn du dann jemand vorgestellte Thermalbad oder schieße Google zusammen,
YouTube everyday my google.
Die Welt ist eine Google.
Ja, Google hatte zwischen 2006 und 2010.
Ein Suchmaschinen Angebot in China die älteren von euch werden sich erinnern.
Erinnere mich da weiter zu allen Gina rum gesagt sind.
Dann haben sie dieses Ding abgeschaltet weil sie tatsächlich Proteste bekommen haben weil wenn man in China.
Einen Onlinedienst anbietet dann gibt's da so bestimmte Vorgaben was da nicht zu finden ist z.b. irgendwie nett zu dem.
Tiananmen.
Unser Navi haben also relativ klare politische Vorgaben was sich im Internet zu finden hat und was nicht.
Asian eine ausufernde blacklist.
Siam eine ausufernde blacklist sie haben vor allem nicht nur eine Blacklist sondern eben auch Zinsen eine staatliche Zensur genannte The Great Wall oder das Internet.
Und so weiter also China hat eine sehr ein sehr eisernen Daumen darauf was über das Internet in China erreichbar ist und was nicht.
Das hat unter anderem zur Folge,
dass sie auch als eines der wenigen Länder dieser Erde einen nennenswerte Internetökonomie aufgebaut haben,
mit diesem Baidu Alibaba wechat diese gesamte Schienen Eddy harness einige der eines der wenigen Länder dieser Erde in der Lage,
sich dem,
Internet Imperialismus der USA zu entziehen mithilfe dieser Menschenrechtsverletzungen,
Zensur Firewall das ganz kurz geschafft zusammenfasst und dann hat sich Google eben auch unter Applaus.
20 X aus China zurückgezogen auch so ein Ding also erst hatten die Proteste aber als sie das getan haben haben sie gesagt hier die Meinungsfreiheit im Internet wird durch Peking Regierungssitz China massiv beschnitten.
Und das können wir nicht mitmachen weil don't be evil so haben sie dann ihren Rückzug aus diesen aus diesem Bereich.
Damals verteidigt ist war auch für alle so ein bisschen klar dass also das sind manevi aufhatte na ja offenbar kriegen die da auch irgendwie mag mag mäßig keinen Fuß auf dem Boden.
Oder so es wurde auch damals schon wie immer wenn ein Unternehmen einen Schritt auch mit moralischen Aspekten begründet da wird man ja auch eher ein bisschen,
skeptisch dieses diese Skepsis hat auch 2010 schon die Entscheidung,
begleitet wird durchaus noch in Erinnerung so jetzt hat Google.
Ein Projekt mit dem Namen Dragonfly die das im Prinzip.
Den Wiedereintritt in den chinesischen Markt zum Ziel hat,
haben und dann hat er sie da also jetzt irgendwie ne heute macht man sowas ja alles mit Karim Suchmaschine mit blockchain geht halt schwierig also muss man das mit KI machen und jetzt rebelliert nicht schlecht.
Das die Google,
Google Belegschaft es gibt regelmäßige workouts also eine im Prinzip von der Arbeitsniederlegung wo dann die Leute rausgehen hat ein sehr,
ranghoher executive dieses Unternehmen verlassen Jack Poulsen.
Buddy the walkers nicht in Bezug.
Wir haben auch diese diversity und 6S es gibt aber auch.
Ark.
Das ist das andere Ding wo irgendwo in jetzt die Belegschaft inzwischen rebellierte the workout zum Thema gabs also.
Offenbar mehrere Fälle von,
Anschuldigung gegenüber Vorgesetzten die sich gegenüber Frauen irgendwie nicht akzeptabel verhalten haben sollen und der Umgang des Unternehmens mit diesen Fällen wurde eben dann auch,
kritisiert im Sinne von also nicht nur intern kritisiert sondern,
offenbar ist die Kultur der so kaputt gewesen dass sie das dann auch nach außen getragen haben was muss man auch sagen ne also,
bei aller Kritik gegenüber einem Unternehmen ja wenn deine eigenen Mitarbeitenden sich schon gegen das Unternehmen richten ja das ist auch ein Warnsignal ja das sollte natürlich solltest du eine Kultur in dem Unternehmen haben dass Leute sich.
In dem Unternehmen kritisch zeigen können und gehört werden dass die nicht nachher nach Öffentlichkeit gehen und dir
öffentliche wie das Messer in den Rücken rammen ja und wenn das wenn das soweit mit deinem Unternehmen gekommen ist dann ist das echt ein Problem weil ehrlich gesagt als Unternehmen solltest du das natürlich nicht gefallen lassen völlig klar dass deine unter deine deine Untergebenen,
ja deine Angestellten auf Linie zu sein haben,
sorry ist so ohne wenn dir das nicht gelingt dann ist das auch ein Führungsstil Problem weil die Freiheit haben die natürlich sowas zu machen Sie mal nach draußen zu gehen und was zu verlangen,
oder sich ein Betriebsrat zu gründen und so weiter also die Freiheit haben diese sollte es natürlich dafür sorgen dass sie diese Freiheit nicht in Anspruch nehmen.
Und das tust du ihm nicht indem das gewaltsam niederschlägt sondern indem du den der Kultur bietet in der sie auch gehört werden das Fühlen dieses offenbar nicht mehr gegeben genauso hat jetzt eben dieser relativ wichtige Erforscher,
bei Google und ich meine es relativ klar dass das ne,
eine gut echt ein wichtiger Mensch ist wenn der an solchen wenn du bei Anna III bei Google arbeitest dann hast du was drauf ja einfach weil Google nur die besten in den Bereichen versucht zu bekommen,
der hat also jetzt hier gesagt überall wegen dieser chinesischen Suchmaschine hat er seine Arbeit niedergelegt weil er mehr oder weniger da nicht dran beteiligt sein möchte,
sundar Pichai der Google Chef sagt dazu in Verteidigung,
99% der Nutzer Anfragen Dianne Dragonfly,
können ohne Zensur beantwortet werden und sagt damit hey, das ist wirklich kein großes Ding wenn wir mal eben hier das jeder hundertste.
Suchanfrage unter unter Berücksichtigung ziehen und er sagt auch das,
bitte den Punkt sollte man zunächst zur Kenntnis nehmen bei einem Markteintritt müssen immer verschiedene Werk vorstellen um den Zugang für Informationen in über einen kleinen gebracht werden Meinungsfreiheit Datenschutz und so weiter,
auch da hat er recht das die zB in Deutschland ja,
Anfragen zu Personen in irgendeiner Weise zensieren müssen obwohl die Pressefreiheit vorschreibt dass die Personen.
Was jetzt einer Berichterstattung war auch immer im Internet ist dazugehören so Sachen wie dass unterschiedliche Länder unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber haben,
wo denn jetzt auf google maps der Grenze zu sein hat und wo nicht ich es auch sehr so je nachdem aus welchem Land du Google Maps.
Israel Palästina cetera.
Sieht es anders aus ne also Teams die Welt ist eine Google das stimmt hier nämlich nicht.
Gigaset es mehrere Google.
Die Welt ist mehrere googeln.
Insofern hat hier dieser CEO von Google durchaus zumindest ein Argument.
Kann man auch anderer Meinung.
Da kann man auch anderer Meinung sein.
Ich kann aber natürlich auch verstehen dass Google wie jedes andere Unternehmen sich um Wachstum bemühen muss,
ist scheint ein bisschen so dass die Felder in den Google,
marktbeherrschend sind er ist mehr oder weniger als auch ihre Wachstumsgrenze erreicht haben und ich kann verstehen dass zehn Jahre nach dem Ausscheiden oder 8 Jahre nach dem Ausscheiden aus China nun der Gedanke,
wieder warm wird bei den Google ziehe aus oder beim beim bei den Google sie's sich zu überlegen wohin können wir denn mit unserem kleinen Scherz hier noch wachsen naja,
das mit dem Social haben wir offenbar so dermaßen verkackt dass das gerade einparken.
Wir müssen uns irgendwie überlegen wie wir hier noch Wachstum hinkriegen und das spielt natürlich China,
eine Rolle das ist eine riesige Nation ein riesiger Markt und man kann verstehen dass Facebook eben sagt ich möchte wir müsse Facebook google sagt wir müssen da irgendwie hin bevor wir dieses Feld eben.
Den chinesischen Alternativen überlassen.
Das sollte man auch nicht da kann man natürlich jetzt so abtut ne wir könnten da so eine westeuropäische Überheblichkeit anlegen sagen,
China und so die Kinder schon wie klein
wann muss ich einfach mal klarmachen wie groß dieser Laden ist und vorallem wo das wirtschaftliche Wachstum ist kapiere jetzt auch gerade noch die Meldung hier deutsche Automobilhersteller der werfen sich dann halt auch
einer umfangreichen Positionsdaten Übermittlungen bei Elektrofahrzeugen in China
das ist da halt einfach mal alles vorgeschriebene sage natürlich ja nee das ist jetzt hier nur um lumby einschätzen zu können wie die benutzt werden und wegen der Sicherheit und so weiter so kennt man natürlich alles schon schon klar wie das da läuft nur
stehst du dann halt am Ende immer vor der Frage als Unternehmen naja machen wir jetzt beim Wachstumsmarkt der nächsten 100 Jahre mit oder lassen wir das einfach sein wegen bedingen.
So und natürlich dann auch immer die Frage dir Google auch am Anfang schon gestellt hat und dieses was ist der größere wert ist es
ist es nicht ein größerer Wert
dass wir einen alternativen Blick auf dieses Internet bieten und in 99% der Fälle hab ja auch wie die Katzenvideos die haben wollt so na ja gut aber jetzt den kritischen Teil den können wir euch leider auch nicht liefert aber wenn wir nicht da wären könnten wir das ja auch,
so nah und das ist keine Entscheidung.
Die leicht fällt weil du hast natürlich dann auch im wirtschaftlichen Umfeld von deiner zu nähren und so weiter den Druck die Fragen ja was mir jetzt mit Wachstumsmarkt und seid ihr überhaupt noch was oder sollen wir die beantragten kaufen,
ist nicht einfach trotzalledem denke ich mal dass es angemessen und Apple hat ja das selbe Problem,
ja da zumindest auch mal also einen moralischen Ankama auszuwerfen und Zusagen nachher hier aber das ist schon das was uns irgendwie leitet
und wir versuchen zumindest irgendein Weg zu finden der das im Rahmen des für uns rechtlich machbar,
lasse auch Apple wird er sicherlich demnächst mit seiner Privatsphären Politik ordentlich sich die Hörner abstoßen.
Die nicht schon ihre iCloud Dinger dann.
Die mussten zumindest sicherstellen dass die Leute in China dass die Server in China sind zwar nicht so dass ihre keys.
Also China und Asien sowieso oder Thailand Asien sowieso ist jetzt,
wichtige Teile Asiens wo du noch ein riesiges Potenzial hast,
auch Wohlstand zu schaffen ja du hast irgendwie in in Indien und China,
das sind ja mal eben zusammen müsste wahrscheinlich so 3 Millionen Leute 3 Milliarden Menschen sein,
wenn ich sogar mehr da hast du größere Teile der Bevölkerung noch nicht mit dem,
durchschnittlichen Wohlstand von den USA oder Europa ausgestattet das kann alles noch passieren das wird alles noch passieren das bedeutet das ist ein,
dass denen das zu verkaufen ja da gibt's noch eine ganze Menge Smartphone die du in die,
verkaufen kannst da gibt's noch eine ganze Menge Online-Dienste die da noch wachsen können die noch Millionen bis Milliarden an Nutzern dort gewinnen können die noch nicht verloren sind weil die noch gar nicht in dieser Welt Sinn.
Gleichzeitig hast du in China ein System das.
Also tatsächlich.
Beängstigenden Effizienz arbeitete sie wenn die sagen ok künstliche Intelligenz ist jetzt ein Thema,
dann gehen die einfach hin und also die die schießt mir eine in China schießen ja so Planstädte aus dem Boden ja weiß ich ob du mal eine besucht hast Chance NZB gab es vor weise ich 20-25 Jahren gar nicht
Dundee gesagt hier ist ein Fischerdorf da steht noch Evo ein Shazam steht noch ein Boot oder so um daran zu erinnern dass da auch mal ein Hafen war da sind die wirklich hingegangen habe gesagt hier einmal statt,
so mach mal hier Universität Universität Universität Fertigungsstätte U-Bahn hier einmal gerade durch Hochhäuser da leben jetzt Leute ZACKBUMM fertig
und dann steht die da wir kriegen Berlin noch nicht mal Flughafen gebaut ja nur um um um da mal die Dimensionen zu vergleichen und wenn die sagen wir wollen jetzt eine bestimmte Bildung in bestimmten Bereich haben.
Dann ziehen die eben ihr wohncampus hin,
verfügen über diesen Unmenschen unglaublichen Pool an Menschen und entscheiden alles klar jetzt hier die nächsten 100 oder die nächsten tausend Absolventen,
die kriegen jetzt einen Studienplatz in Informatik und zwar dort,
das ist ja nicht so dass da jemand ich mache aber erstmal noch einen selbst finde es ja oder die so eine Unverschämtheit wie der zentralen Vergabestelle für Studienplätze unterwerfe ich mich nicht,
sondern die wenn einfach ab geordert das steht nicht zur Debatte dass du sagst ich möchte aber ne das ist einfach da sind dann ganz andere Kultur,
und dann hast du dann Menschen dann hast du eine Kultur in diesem Land wo dieser geil Fortschritt machen mitmachen,
und passiert dann eben auch die bauen dir bin ja immer wieder in Asien begasse Bonnie eine U-Bahn die hält immer an der gleichen Stelle,
Bild so dermaßen immer an der gleichen Stelle das in den Boden eingegossen ist in Marmor wo die Tür ist und dass du bitte an den Rändern der Tür stehst mit den grünen Pfeilen draußen rothenrain sowas bauen die bis man in Berlin U Bahn gefahren kannst froh sein wenn die anhält weil der
was ist bei der Taufe.
Ich kenne es auch schon aus Japan das ist ja genauso.
Naja fand das ist ja sowieso einfach nur noch erniedrigend aber.
China kommt und die Welt die kommen mit einer Geschwindigkeit und mit einer entschied einer Kraft der Entscheidung die unglaublich ist und gleichzeitig eben auch mit diesem Jahr Datenschutz nee.
Und freies Internet auch nicht wir planen das ja hier ne natürlich haben wir denn diese sehr skurrilen trotzdem Milliardäre die die ist ja dann irgendwie schaffen,
aber auch nur solange die das im Prinzip so machen wir dass wir dass das ZK gerne möchte das ist wirklich Interesse also beängstigend und beeindruckend zugleich.
Und da die haben heute schon irgendwie Wirtschaftskraft und Umsatz der irgendwie.
Mit mit unseren Verhältnissen nicht vergleichbar dieses dieses Amazon Cyber Monday.
Melanie sich Schrott drüber Nadine die machen ja auf ihrem Alibaba irgendwie einen ein X Faches,
an einem einzigen Tag im Vergleich zu dem was irgendwie in dem dämlichen Cyber Monday ist oder sowas passiert ne.
Ja die paar hundert Millionen Leute.
100000000 so ach was das hat jetzt das ist bei denen also wenn wir 100 Millionen Klicks hätten pro Sekunde da immer wenn wir uns Sorgen machen ob irgendwie einen Server ausgefallen so ungefähr sind da die die Dimension.
Ja was soll ich mit uns rummachen würden kann chinesisches.
Weil ich leider nicht chinesisch.
Haben weil ich könnte dich ja Freunde die sowohl beides sprechen ne bei der Country & Western Chinesisch ja.
Wir werden ja auch hoffentlich wenn es nicht wieder mal ausfällt wird Platten das schon länger noch mal einen Spezial machen und die chinesische Situation noch mal ein bisschen genauer beleuchten
aber nicht zuviel versprechen mehr liefern damit du mir jetzt durch was kann man denn noch.
Also wir haben noch wenn wir jetzt funktioniert die Themen rantensee 30 echt schon aneinander wo wir gerade bei,
Beims Internet waren und der Zensur ja komme jetzt zur Artikel 13 wie sollte es schöner sein kurzes Update von Julia Reda,
wir wissen die Copyright Direktive ist ja nun im Trilog und der uns immer noch interessieren der Kernpunkt ist der Artikel 13 die Haftung bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Und der ist ja gleichermaßen ein bisschen der Kampf zwischen YouTube und den Rechteinhabern oder Rechteverwerter an die Rechteverwerter sagen ist kann ja wohl nicht sein,
das hier jemand unsere Urheberrechte verletzt oder dass wir dafür Geld bekommen das muss verhindert werden,
und YouTube die sagen naja wir wollen eigentlich hier so eine Plattform machen also wollten eigentlich eigentlich bei unserem Plattform er schon so ein bisschen freies Internet und interessant ist also es gibt hier bezieht die beiden Interessenvertreter ganz klar YouTube und Rechteinhaber ja,
so etwas wie die armen Künstler über die hier die ganze Zeit argumentiert wird das die sitzen er natürlich nicht mit am Tisch ne das ist klar.
Die dürfen ja nicht mit verhandelt und es ist auch relativ unklar ob die am Ende von dieser ganzen Copyright Direktive überhaupt nur mal etwas haben,
werden das Risiko am Horizont ist natürlich das Massen blocking davor warnt auch YouTube,
es gibt,
einfach keine zentrale Sammlung der urheberrechtlichen Werke wo man quasi sein könnte hier ist die die Ohren der blockchain machen hier ist Diurese Mamablog.
Das wäre,
die Domain,
das wirklich.
Ilnp privat blockchain mit in Unterschleißheim.
40 Millionär geworden.
Merge.
Die aufzeichnen das könnte für deiner blockschema.
Lippenstift.
Okay kannst dich ja.
Thalwitzer.
Ich würde mit Rolladen.
Na da hätten allen extrem großes Interesse dass das immer läuft irgendwie so man wäre das cool aber leider benutzen wir das nur für Anna.
Mein etwas auf wer auch immer damit reich wird ne wenn der Zuckerberg das morgen baut,
wir haben jetzt wenigstens unsere lautlos die Folge hier in die blockchain.
Dass wir die Idee als erstes halten.
Kältezentrale Sammlung der urheberrechtliche Werke wo man ersetzt sagen könnte nee das gehört jetzt schon hier.
Und selbst YouTube kann das ja auch nicht leisten die haben ja das beste System Content-ID aber auch das hat Lücken ne jetzt ist also die Frage wie das ist also,
im Prinzip die Situation es wird nicht möglich sein zu blocken ohne dass es einen.
Darf man in beide Richtungen Fehler macht Alpha Fehler und Beta Fehler also eine Urheberrechtsverletzung passiert obwohl sie hätte geblockt werden müssen und etwas wird als Urheberrechtsverletzung geblockt obwohl es nicht hätte geblockt werden dürfen.
Das Parlament bewegt sich so ein bisschen in Richtung,
trusted sources ja also die Plattform darf nur noch zulassen,
Leute bei denen irgendwie klar ist dass man,
dass dass das in die Quellen sind von denen jetzt keine Urheberrechtsverstöße unbedingt ausgehen werden in größerer Menge Julian enters in den Blogbeitrag,
cable TV two-point also es gibt eine ganze Menge sender wir sind ewig zugelassen deren die Lizenz zum YouTube hochladen.
Und damit wäre das Thema erledigt die Rats Version von Artikel 13 GTA in Richtung
Filternetz ja also die großen Plattformen können filtern und tun das ja auch also Content-ID und jetzt soll sie das eben einfach auch für andere tun das heißt nur fair den upload-filter,
hat der profitiert auch von einer Haftungserleichterung mit anderen Worten ein Content Filter wird,
zwingend notwendig und wer kann den bereitstellen YouTube ja also dann könnt ihr quasi sah und Content-ID hat YouTube ja schon irgendwie weiß nicht viele Millionen gekostet.
Und man könnte sagen so wird jetzt eben Content-ID zum Profitcenter und zum Datenlieferanten für YouTube beides scheiße.
Und Axel Voss sagt nun Herpes auf YouTube und Rechteinhaber vielleicht klärt ihr das einfach unter uns,
unter euch so ein bisschen wie Trump ne,
der in Israel Palästina Konflikt gatinha genial gelöst mir ist völlig egal wie oh ich eine Stich,
bin zufrieden solange jederzeit ja verdammt noch mal das ist der Israel-Palästina-Konflikt der existiert weil nicht alle zufrieden sind
naja und so ungefähr verhält sich Axel Force jetzt in der Abwägung dieser Interessen,
und natürlich die unabhängigen Kulturschaffende schaffen im bleiben ungehört und genau um die geht es ja eigentlich die müssten eigentlich am Tisch sitzen wie,
Julia Reda sind voll und am Ende bliebe dann nur noch mal,
das ganze die ganze Direktive zu killen wenn da jetzt nicht mal auf eine sinnvolle Lösung hingearbeitet.
Das schön wie sie jetzt alle ansehen auf einmal dass es vielleicht doch nicht so ganz das ist was sie eigentlich haben wollten und haben sie ein bisschen Salat.
Können sie ja mit denen können sie ja mit Theresa May aushandeln.
Also ich meine es wirklich extrem untypisch dass jetzt etwas im Trilog noch,
den Eindruck macht überhaupt so aus der Spur zu geraten dass das ganz allgemein die Unterstützungen verliert aber wenn ihr zur Zeit auch noch die
die ganze Zeit für die das die ganze Zeit gemacht wurde sagen soigné so war das aber jetzt nicht gemeint.
Das könnte noch ein Novum werden auf jeden Fall zeigt es schön wie bekloppt diese ganze Debatte die ganze Zeit gelaufen ist und mal gucken vielleicht ist das ja auch noch Teil des politischen Frühlings.
So Mama bevorsteht.
Netzpolitischer Frühling steht auf dem Amt der Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit.
Gedacht ihr euch wieso die ist doch gerade erst Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte geworden die hat doch noch gar nichts gemacht ja so schnell geht das vorbei ne so ist das vorbei,
kaum bist du Datenschutzbeauftragte oder hast du bist gar nicht dazu gekommen überhaupt mal irgendwie zu Wort zu kommen überhaupt mal deine erste Amtshandlung zu vollführen schon wird jemand anders viele Jahre später.
Andrea voßhoff geht Nachfolger Ulrich Kelber vor längerer Zeit ja schon,
vom Bundestag gewählt wenn er jetzt zum vom Bundestag gewählt worden ist aber schon länger klar dass das der designierte war es ist jemand der.
Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung kritisch ist oder wie war es noch mal warm war kritisch Staatstrojaner war kritisch Vorratsdatenspeicherung glaube ich nicht.
Oder umgekehrt naja.
Hier steht da spinnt er stimmte im Parlament mit der großen Koalition dafür eine verdachtsunabhängige Protonierung von Protokollierung von Nutzerdaten vorzunehmen ja also er ist
gegen Staatstrojaner aber für Vorratsdatenspeicherung mal sehen ja wir begrüßen den guten Herrn.
Kälber im Amt Kälber mit EC März.
SharePoint der post office seid jetzt unverrichteter Dinge in den Ruhestand versetzt worden nicht nicht in den Ruhestand über aus diesem Abend zumindest ausgeschieden.
Also bis Anfang Januar na dann.
Immer noch nicht.
Ja sorry.
Gut Anfang Januar wird forsthoff gehen meine Quitte okay dann wissen was jetzt und.
Dann hat er noch einen kleinen Hack Planet ist gut 500 Millionen.
Hotelgäste der Daten wurden abgegriffen bei der Hotelkette Starwood die aber 2016 von Marriott gekauft wurde.
Haben und bis zu 500 Millionen,
Hotelgäste wurden also jetzt irgendwie deren Name Adresse Telefonnummer E-Mail-Adresse Passnummer Geburtsdatum Geschlecht Ankunftsdatum Abreisedatum reservierungs Datum und so weiter,
abgegriffen bei Marriott.
Alter was für ein Datenschutz.
Herr ist ein schöner ein großer Datensatz und bis jetzt ist er nicht irgendwie gelegt worden wann kann er selbst darüber spekulieren ob das jetzt nur für Identitätsdiebstahl verwendet wird oder auch ob das jetzt ein Geheimdienst war oder so.
Oder falls mal eine Hotelkette eröffnen möchte.
Ja also keine Ahnung vielleicht was werden sehen was damit passiert interessant finde ich dass es jetzt natürlich was ist jetzt ne,
wie kann ich jetzt nach dsgvo gegen die vorgehen weil meine Daten sind auch in diesem Datensatz drin haben.
Achso der feine Herr.
Der feine Herr ja war als ich aber auch mal in einem Hotel ja.
Also merit hat sicherlich nicht nur eine 1 Stab habe ich ja noch nie gehört also ist hier zur zeigen nur wenn man in einem Starwood Hotel war oder in.
Dauert es eine South ist eine Hotelgruppe,
denen sowas gehört wie Sheraton Four Points doubleyou Westen.
Ja und noch eine Reihe andere ja und Marriott ist diese andere große Hotelkette denen eben die Marriott Hotels gehören und sowas wie die Renaissance Hotels und sowas alles ja und,
David wurde eben 2016 glaube ich von Marriott gekauft.
Die dafür ist ne wenn sich Markte Märkte konsolidieren.
Also kann ich mir jetzt.
Im einzelnen Anbieter.
Mir fällt gerade jetzt keinen Hotelname konkret eine aber die wahrscheinlich.
Le Meridian.
Irgendwo schon mal war ist nicht ganz gering.
Fast jedes größere Hotel das eine Kette ist und sagen wir mal mehr oder mindestens drei Sterne hat gehört eigentlich zu zu Starwood oder zu Marriott.
Radisson es war nicht dabei und hätte mal auf dich.
Radisson gehört den Park Nährwerte wem gehört Radisson noch mal also Radisson gehört nicht zu SPG,
also nicht tut nicht zu Star Wars ich gucke gerade mal wo gibt's denn hier meine Liste welche Hotels ahir Ritz-Carlton rd
im Moment wenn die Starwood Hotels Sandwiches luxury doubleyou Western Sheridan nierenmeridian
für Cube Portfolio Designhotel sale of four points und Element das sind die Starwood Hotels Marriott sind.
Gaylord Hotels courtyard genau courtyard Residence Spring Hill Fairfield towneplace,
moxy das moxy Hotel ne auch ein bisschen günstiger Hotels,
Delta Renaissance orthographic Collection im Prinzip Ritz-Carlton und so weiter also alles so die größeren Ketten der luxuriösen.
Hotels ab denke ich mal so drei bis fünf tja so siehts aus Daten weg.
Der ist auch nicht im woanders die sind ja jetzt nur ihr woanders sie sind ja nicht weg fragt sich wie werde ich jetzt kompensiert als betroffene Person ja,
was passiert wirklich jetzt mein Geld her in den USA gezeigt und class action lawsuit der die moderate Entschädigung von 25 $.
Pro betroffener Personen.
Fordert das ist denke ich nicht die Maximalforderung wenn man aber jetzt diese 25 $ x 500000000 rechnet dann ist das eine.
12 Billionen.
Alles was man mit 500 Millionen Mal nimmt ist eine große Zahl.
Eine sehr große Zeit fünfeinhalb billion wär das ne also eine 12 mit 90.
Das ist immer noch relativ viel Geld was da jetzt unter Umständen eine Rolle spielt,
und es stellt sich natürlich die Frage warum haben die überhaupt diese riesigen Daten,
noch davor gehalten in meinen Augen ist ein Hotelaufenthalt erledigt in dem Moment wo ich da rein gehen meine Rechnung bezahlt habe und die Rechnung nach Hause nehmen.
Najvise aber na weil das natürlich wunderbare Daten sind wohl so schlimm big-data mäßig
drin rumpfuschen kann um einfach patterns zu erkennen wie verhalten sich Leute wann und sie wo steigen Sie wann zu welchen Jahreszeiten in was für eine Art Hotels ab und so das wär alles durchaus nachvollziehbar auch Business Daten die man auswerten möchte um einfach zu verstehen diese Kundschaft.
Insbesondere dann glaube ich dazu sagen also diese Hotels sind,
besonder also diese Ketten entfalten ihre Kraft ja dadurch durch hauptsächlich durch ihre loyalty programme,
und dadurch dass sie mit den größeren Unternehmen die viele Reisetätigkeit haben natürlich auch special dieses haben also sowas wie McKinsey,
na die mehr oder weniger ihre konnten die ganze Zeit nur durch die Welt schicken die haben natürlich spezifische Deals mit Starwood Marriott und so weiter,
und entsprechen siehst du an diesen Daten natürlich jetzt auch welche McKinsey Consultant oder nimm eine andere consultancy wann wo waren,
wer wo gearbeitet hat welche Projekte wo hochgezogen wurden und wenn man das jetzt noch mit dem mit irgendwie vielleicht eine linkedin Datensatz abgleicht oder so dann ergibt sich da ein sehr interessantes Bild der internationalen,
Projekte wo welcher.
Aber auch wo sind Lobby Leute untergekommen wo sind Politiker wann wo auch auf einmal gehäuft aufgetreten also da kann man wirklich eine ganze Menge raus lesen wo irgendwas ist.
Das ist auf jeden Fall mal Big Data das ist wirklich mal bitte da viele wollen ja nur Big Data macht das ist.
Das ganz ohne.
Und auch gleichzeitig dass es halten Milliardenunternehmen die waren in der nicht in der Lage diese Daten,
sicher zu verwahren in der gleichen Woche sind ja noch irgendwo überall in anderen Unternehmen ihr welche Daten Reichtümer aufgetreten Quora und UVA und was kann ich die schaffen es ja schon gar nicht mehr alle in die Sendung,
und es ist wirklich so die Chance sich mein Design und dieser Marriott Heck hat auch nur deshalb in die Sendung geschafft war das jetzt wahrscheinlich der größte ist bei der größer als der größer ist als die.
Afifa schöner Factor 500000000 ding ding könnte man auch aufs nächste Thema mal anwenden den Faktor.
Faktor 500 Millionär wenn man schon mal so eine Zahl haben die Netzagentur droht der Deutschen Telekom für die weitere Durchführung von streamon mit einer Strafe von.
500000000.
Dr evil lache 200000 €.
Hahaha jetzt haben wir es euch aber gezeigt.
Elsa was euch gegeben.
Also mit anderen Worten mit Portokasse.
Und damit wären wir bei den Termin würde ich sagen.
Besser jetzt nichts dazu zu sagen außer wir haben wir haben zu streamon eine Reihe Kommentare bekommen in der letzten Sendung.
Und zwar zeigte sich ja einige einigermaßen Ratlosigkeit bei allen darüber wie es denn jetzt bei streamon ist wann da was wie drin ist und wann nicht und erklärte uns.
Im Moment,
Rico klärte uns auf zum Thema streamon Netflix ist nicht immer mit drin Video gibt kostenlos erst ab Magenta L dazu,
da ist die Aussage zwei Gigabyte reichen sein als Tarif auch falsch ich habe vier Gigabit Volumen und Netflix und Co zählen voll drauf das heißt jetzt wahrscheinlich diesen m.
Es gibt also weiterhin eine Produktdifferenzierung über den Preis und deswegen macht die Telekom auch keine Flat für jeden das ist natürlich der entscheide. In dem Moment wo sie eine Flat für alle machen ist eine Flat,
für alle,
widerspricht aber Christian sagt es reicht z.b. Magenta m wenn man DSL auch von der Telekom bezieht das ist dann dieses magentaeins dann ist Fremont Video auch in HD möglich.
Nicht nur wie in der Folgezeit dargestellt in STL keine Ahnung wenn er ernsthaft zur Deutschen Telekom gehen wollt und einprägsam hast du illegales Angebot finanzieren Volt,
buchen möchtet dann guckt euch das selber an wir sind hier nicht der T-Punkt gibt noch den Punkte eigentlich,
es gibt auf jeden Fall noch für Läden fericite. Das war noch so Zeiten geheißen ich weiß gar nicht wie alt.
Bestimmten viel Geschmack vorderen Namen haben sich jetzt aus.
Tipp.
So aber ganz groß ist drin.
Also genau wir unsere.
Kaufberatung für die Deutsche Telekom ist nicht unsere Stärke aber ihr seht auch da ist natürlich eigentlich in dieser Produkte Fränzchen finde ich spielt auch immer verwirrend hat er den größeres immer merkt dass das auf Verwirrung angelegt ist ne.
Naja so ich würde sagen jetzt kommen wir aber tatsächlich zu den Terminen.
So ist es und wir fangen an mit dem 12. Dezember in Berlin gibt es die Vorstellung des Films all creatures welcome im Kino International für dass ihr euch zudem Zeit,
wo ihr das hier hört sicherlich noch ein paar Tickets blicken könnt ja da wird der Film gezeigt der dokumentiert ein wenig das Geschehen auf Camp und Kongress,
und wagt einen kulturellen Blick auf die Chaos Sehne.
Am 31.12 um 4 Uhr morgens.
Gibt es auf dem 35 C3 Schunkelmusik mit einer Besen und rosa Luxus nur für Leute mit Ticket.
Und ich kann nur soviel sagen es ist der letzte Slot und ich glaube die haben sich gedacht da können die nicht mehr viel kaputtmachen.
Wenn das wenn das zigmal bewahrheiten würde.
Eventim.
Nur für Leute mit Ticket muss ich dazu sagen.
Neitsch,
wer so kurzfristig nicht planen kann kann sich ja schon mal aufschreiben am 28 Februar gibt es in Bamberg eine Buchvorstellung von dem,
Cyberwar was wir ja mit Frank Rieger einem der Autorin schon hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon mal ordentlich durch gesprochen haben von der wisse was auf euch,
zukommt und mehr haben wir nicht in unserem Termin Angebot.
Wie als würde die Termin Einreichung für den für die Lesung oder die Buchvorstellung in Bamberg bekommen haben habe ich zurückgeschrieben dass du ganz ehrlich so weit im Voraus spannberg.
Ich brauchen etwas länger oder was.
Verkehrt das jetzt schon mal anzukündigen damit die sich darauf einrichten können ja keine Ahnung wir werden was glaube ich auch dann noch mal im Februar daran erinnern.
So sind wir schon durch keine zwei Stunden später.
Ja ich danke zur sichtlich mehreren,
unbekannten Person wo also kein Name mit geschwappt ist ich vermute immer dass das dann euer eure Absicht war und danke wenn es nicht eure Absicht war dann bitte einfach noch mal.
Über die Kontaktierung essmöglichkeiten melden weiß was ich vergessen habe zu erwähnen wollte tatsächlich nur auserwählen eigentlich in der.
Ist noch nicht vorbei hast noch nicht.
Kommen wir zum Teil wie geht's uns denn nein.
Kissen set.
Die die Bühnenshow von methodisch inkorrekt habe ich mir angeschaut.
Da konnte ich ja leider nicht.
Ja ich bin dass ich bin ja etwas SMS etwas skeptisch hingegangen im Sinne von der überleben so ist es.
Ziemt es sich funktioniert es da quasi ein Bühnenprogramm zu machen was dann in zumindest inhaltlich gleicher Form,
auf einer Tournee ja quasi angeboten wird ne die Tingle ja jetzt durch die Republik irgendwie in München osnabrück-berlin.
Boxers halt man kennt das Hotel Rogen.
Hotels zertrümmern das ganze Ding ne und im,
bin ja ein bisschen skeptisch ob das vor allem auch für die beiden passt der redselige Menschen muss man ganz ehrlich sagen und die war ich war skeptisch ob dass das richtige für Sie ist,
wie gesagt ich habe einfach nur ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch in gehabt dann mal gucken wie das jetzt wird bei in Berlin gab es auch zwei Termine in der 2 an aufeinanderfolgenden Tagen und ich war skeptisch.
Und ich muss sagen das ist doch durchaus sehenswert absolut sehenswert der sich wirklich Mühe gegeben und
wir haben es nachher auch ein bisschen noch unterhalten wo du halt siehst ja ne wenn du das eben auch mehrfach vorführen kannst dann gibt's hier vielleicht auch noch mal mit dem Intro noch mal ein bisschen mehr Mühe und gibst dir für die,
für den Verein für den roten Faden,
der Sendung noch mal mehr rüber und den roten Faden der Tag ich sag immer sein und der der Feind des Abends der rote Faden ist sehr sehr schön und sehr sehr wichtig gewählt denn sie behandeln im weitesten Sinne.
Jetzt aber nicht spoilern.
Nein nein sag mir mal.
Den Teil derbe sehr ge sellschaft mit Reinhard nannte das besonderen Weltbild Menschen mit besonderem Weltbild.
Kannst du mir schon.
Mit besonderem Weltbild das jetzt erstmal mit der Wissenschaft nicht mehr so ganz in Einklang steht.
Und haben dann da eine Reihe an Experimenten die in diesem Bereich
ein bisschen Klarheit schaffen und finden machen da eben ein wichtiges Plädoyer für ich sag mal eine evidenzbasierte Herangehensweise an,
Phänomene seines,
natur natürliche naturwissenschaftliche Phänomene aber auch politische Phänomene und das ist gelungen dass es unterhaltsam und das ist sehenswert und das finde ich finde ich wirklich,
toll und wichtig hat mich sehr sehr darüber gefreut und kann das tatsächlich nur empfehlen es gibt in verschiedenen Städten noch Tickets in einigen Städten sind die Chance auch jetzt schon ausverkauft.
Und wirklich sehenswert wirklich toll das.
Richtig das Prädikat Empfehlung muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
wegen dieses roten Fadens und dieser dieser des auch wichtigen Statements ja und dann ist es eben auch wirklich schön und amüsant aufbereitet das ist eine das sind,
dreieinhalb 4 Stunden was heißt ihr nicht bereuen werdet kann ich empfehlen.
Schön ich hoffe ich werde auch noch mal die Gelegenheit bekommen jetzt habe ich dir leider verpassen müssen an diesem Wochenende wo es sich so angeboten hätte ja mit unseren Format geht das ja nicht ne wir müssen immer was neues.
Das war ja auch so ein bisschen Weine der daher war ja kann ja auch meine Skepsis ohne weil das machen sie ja auch in der Sendung über ja auch alle alle 14 Tage jetzt gerade sehr weniger,
eine neue neuen Blick auf die die Wissenschaft und.
Da war ich eben auch überrascht oder war ich eben habe ich mich gefragt wie sie diese Herausforderungen lösen.
Und ob das Format nicht dadurch er verliert aber sie haben sehr gelungen die Kurve gekriegt das ist Format dadurch ihr tatsächlich gewinnt.
Naja soviel also dazu und.
Dann will ich sagen komme Euch in die zurück in zurück damit zurück zum Google.
Zurück zurück in die Zukunft mit euch.